Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zurück in der Liga Tour zu Europa. Wir wollen heute blicken auf die Eredivisi. Wir wollen schauen nach Spanien und nach Italien. Und das tun wir mit Daniel Zander, Fabian Pakulat und Christian Bernhardt jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Linien.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt und schön, dass ich unsere bekannte Runde hier zurück habe. Ich sag einfach mal hallo in die Runde an euch drei. Ihr könnt kollektiv antworten oder auch gar nicht. Entscheidet euch jetzt.
Hallo. Hallo.
Ah, das war ja auch total ungezwungen und freiwillig so mögen wir es doch am liebsten in der Ligatur. Schön, dass ihr hier seid und schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir blicken heute auf die eben schon genannten drei Ligen. Ich würde sagen, Fabian, wenn du magst, dann fang du doch mal an. Was hast du uns denn aus Spanien mitgebracht?
Du weißt, ich bring dir ja normalerweise gerne Teams mit, die nicht so bekannt sind und die irgendwie Nachrichten von sich schreiben oder irgendwie was zu vermelden ist. Aber ich kann im Moment aus La Liga eigentlich nur über The Big Three oder The Big Two berichten, über Barcelona, Real Madrid und Atletico Madrid. Die sind die einzigen, die im Moment tatsächlich für Nachrichten sorgen auf und neben dem Platz. Alle anderen Teams sind noch ein bisschen im Winterschlaf, habe ich so das Gefühl und haben stark abgerissen jetzt über die Winterpause beziehungsweise ja über das neue Jahr. Und ja, deswegen muss ich mich eigentlich auf diese großen drei beziehen und möchte vor allen Dingen Barcelona und Real Madrid hervorheben, die im Moment wieder richtig gut drauf sind. Barcelona sehr, sehr stark, vor allen Dingen offensiv natürlich, habt ihr vielleicht mitbekommen. Wir haben am Wochenende 7-1 gegen Valencia gewonnen. Es gab dieses verrückte Champions League Spiel gegen Benfica, Alissabon, dass sie noch 5-4 in der Verlängerung gewonnen haben. Nachspielzeit, aber für die Spieleanbieter Verlängerung ist man so viele Tore, dass das Ergebnis aus dem Elbmeterschießen ist.
Da kann man schon mal durcheinander kommen.
Ja, nein, aber es war einfach für mich ein bisschen sinnbildlich, was die bisherigen Saison von Barcelona so ein bisschen auszeichnet oder ausmacht. Sie hatten ja mal im Herbstende, so im November, um eine Ergebniskrise, ich finde nicht eine spielerische Krise, aber eine Ergebniskrise, haben dort ein bisschen abgelassen, nachdem sie unwahrscheinlich stark gestartet sind mit Hansi Flick und sind jetzt aber auch ergebnismäßig wieder back on track. Und ja, haben einfach eine unglaubliche Spielfreude. Viele junge Talente aus der eigenen Masseer. Da vorne noch ein Lewandowski, der mit 36 Jahren wieder unglaubliche Quoten hat. Im Moment führende ist der Torschützenliste mit 17 Treffern und ja, genau. Und dementsprechend muss man über den FC Barcelona sprechen, weil er einfach im Moment mit Abstand, würde ich sagen, den schönsten Fußball in Spanien spielt. Und genau, uns einfach richtig gut anzusehen ist. Und Real Madrid hat gleichzeitig wieder zurückgefunden in die gewohnte Konstanz der königlichen, sag ich jetzt mal.
Aber lass mich ganz kurz bei Barcelona bleiben, bevor du jetzt mit der EI weiter machst. Weil ich glaube, da wird auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer interessieren. Es gab ja diesen kleinen Leistungsabfall, vor allem in den Ergebnissen. Du hast es jetzt in der Ergebniskrise genannt. Vor allem mit dem 0 zu 1 gegen Leganes zu Hause auch noch. Leganes natürlich. Und dann gegen Atletico hat man verloren, das ist auch schon früher mal passiert. Aber es gab so ein bisschen dann das Narrativ, jetzt ist Flick entschlüsselt und das ganze Risiko, es ist zu hoch und jetzt kommen die Gegner besser mit Barca. Klar, plus es gab ja auch noch ein paar Ausfälle und jetzt dann im Winter noch das ganze Dani Olmo Theater. Also es war ja schon sehr, sehr viel los. Aber wie würdest du denn auf dieses Narrativ antworten? War es dann wirklich einfach nur Zufall, diese Niederlagen oder hat sich auch was verändert bei Barca danach?
Also ich habe vor allen Dingen das Spiel gegen Atletico Madrid vor Augen, das sie dann mit 1-2 glaube ich noch verloren haben, auch mit dem Treffer in der Nachspielzeit ganz unglücklich in den Konter gelaufen. Und da war Barcelona die bessere Mannschaft und hätte ja den Siegtreffer erzielen müssen können sollen und dann fangen sie tatsächlich einen Konter und bekommen dieses Gegentor. Und ich glaube, dass zumindest dann in der Mannschaft dahingehend eine kleine Umstellung stattgefunden hat, dass man sagt, okay, wir können jetzt nicht nur noch Hauruck nach vorne, hurra, sondern wir müssen vielleicht auch ein bisschen aufpassen. Ich hab das schon gemerkt, vielleicht lacht jetzt der eine oder andere, aber als die Bayern in der Champions League gegen Barca gespielt haben, das haben die Bayern zwar 4-1 verloren, aber ich glaube, die Bayern hatten deutlich mehr Torschüsse und Barca hat einfach unwahrscheinlich effektiv gekontert und hat eigentlich mit vier oder fünf Torschüssen dann eben vier Tore erzielt. Also man hat schon gemerkt, wo Barca zu knacken ist, weil sie halt eben sehr hoch spielen, weil sie sehr tief in die Tiefe gehen und weil du sie normalerweise dann auch hinten schön reinbohren kannst. Und ja, ich denke mal, dass zumindest Flick und Markus Sorg, der ja damals für Flick ein paar Wochen übernommen hat, auch weil Flick gesperrt war, dass sie sich vielleicht ihre Spieler darin gehen, ein bisschen angewiesen haben, nicht ganz so hauruckmäßig nach vorne zu gehen bzw. hinten so ein bisschen abzusichen. Wir haben Frenkie de Jong jetzt öfter gesehen, der hinten ein bisschen sichern soll. Marc Casado bleibt hinten. Gabi ist zurückgekommen. Auch wichtige Personalier würde ich sagen, auch der defensiv natürlich nochmal Zeichen setzen kann. Offensiv sowieso, brauchen wir gar nicht drüber sprechen, aber der halt auch noch ein bisschen mehr beißt als ein Pedri zum Beispiel. Und genau. Und wenn sie halt vorne drin sind, dann kannst du ganz wenig machen gegen Bassa.
Darf ich ganz kurz nur ein, zwei zu Bassa oder auch eine Frage dann an Fabian? Also ich finde es klar, im Januar kann man ihnen ja kaum was vorwerfen, haben jetzt ja alles gewonnen, bis eben dieses Getaffespiel. Und das ganze Offensiv, das ist ja wirklich herausragend, die können dich ja wirklich aus dem Stadion schießen. Deswegen, ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass die glaube ich für die Champions League nochmal heißer sind, weil die über 180 Minuten zu verteidigen, ist halt ein Hin- und Rückspiel, ist halt wahnsinnig schwierig. Da können sie vielleicht auch ein bisschen was zulassen. Aber ich finde es schon brutal, dass sie oft dieser Wahnsinnssaison allein zwei Spiele gegen Real 10 Tore in der Supercoppa in der Liga, dass sie sieben Punkte Rückstand auf Real haben. Und sieben Punkte Rückstand in der Liga ist halt Wahnsinn, weil du hast logisch noch das direkte Duell. Klar, da kannst du nochmal die drei Punkte wegmachen. Aber selbst wenn du auf vier dann rankommst, also obwohl die so eine Saison spielen, finde ich es schon fast tragisch, dass die sieben Punkte zurück sind. Dass da eben diese Unentschieden, die sie da teilweise drin hatten und auch jetzt dieses 1-1 gegen Getafe, ja eigentlich darfst du dir das fast nicht leisten. Also ich finde es schwer zu erklären, weil alles was du sagst, ist ja wirklich beeindruckend, das Offensive. Aber mit so einer Leistung und mit so einem Potenzial trotzdem jetzt schon und gegen Real Madrid, wo wir ja auch schon oft in der Saison darüber gesprochen hatten, dass es ja lange nicht bei Real soli lief, wie man sich das immer gedacht hat. Und jetzt trotzdem 7 Punkte zurück sein, ist eigentlich fast ein Frevier.
Du hast schon recht, weil vor allen Dingen selbst wenn du den Klassiker gewinnst, dann sind es immer noch 4 Punkte und Real Madrid lässt sich normalerweise gegen alle Teams ab Platz 4 nichts mehr nehmen und dementsprechend gebe ich dir da vollkommen recht. Ich denke, dass Barca einfach auch ein bisschen den Feld ein bisschen abgezockt hat. Die haben halt viele junge Spieler bei Real Madrid. Weißt du selbst, wer da spielt? Das sind nochmal ganz andere Kaliber und die wissen halt in bestimmten Situationen vielleicht besser zu reagieren, während ein Lamin Yamal oder ein Ferran Torres oder ein Fermin Lopez oder wie sie alle heißen oder Pedri Gavi. Ja, halt dann vielleicht eher nochmal den Gang nach vorne suchen und diese Spielfreude ausdrücken, aber halt vielleicht vergessen hinten abzusichern. Auch die beiden Außenverteidiger, die ich sehr stark finde mit Jules Condé oder Alex Balde, die sind offensiv wahnsinnig, aber defensiv. Dann hast du mit Kouvasin, 18-jährigen in der Innenverteidigung. Der macht auch noch ab und zu Fehler, obwohl der unwahrscheinlich stark auch spielt. Indigo Martinez, der teilweise neben ihm spielt, ist auch so ein wackeliger. Also wenn man Barser unter Druck setzt, dann können die schon zu Problemen kommen. Und dieses Ergebnis, diese Krise, die sie hatten, die wird ihnen wehtun und das wird schwer mit der Meisterschaft. Der Champions League wiederum, gebe ich dir recht, 180 Minuten. Schwierige Kiste.
Aber baut uns ja auch schon die Brücke zu Real, die eben einfach, das eben einfach wesentlich weniger Punkte liegen hat lassen und deswegen ja eine absolut souveräne Saison spielt unterm Strich, auch wenn sich vielleicht nach außen hin gar nicht so anfühlt. Aber wenn man sich die Bilanz in der Liga anguckt, zwei Niederlagen, 50 Tore geschossen, 20 kassiert. Das ist nach 21 Spielen ganz wunderbar. Trotzdem hat man natürlich dann auch 0-2 gegen Liverpool oder so noch im Hinterkopf. Aber was unterscheidet denn dann real von Barca? Ist es nur die Erfahrung oder hat da auch etwas zueinander gefunden? Ich meine, jetzt hatte Mbappé seinen ersten Hatschack. Ich weiß aber jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also das sind halt dann so Headlines, die kommen halt dann bei einem an, auch wenn man nicht auf Liga guckt. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es für was Größeres tatsächlich steht.
Ein bisschen schon. Ich glaube vor allen Dingen, das Zusammenspiel vorne hat am Anfang halt nicht funktioniert. Mit Vinicius, mit Bellingham, mit Mbappé, auch mit den anderen, Rodrigo und so weiter. Da kamen zur Büffelherde eben Neuer dazu und der musste sich erst mal einfinden. Und Mbappé selbst hat im Interview vor einer Woche oder vor zwei Wochen ein Statement abgeliefert, weil sie gefragt haben, warum es jetzt besser läuft. Und er ist am Anfang auch seiner Aussage nach ein bisschen demütig zu den königlichen Kreisen, wollte sich nicht gleich in den Vordergrund spielen, wollte nicht gleich jeden Ball fordern, wollte sich erst mal einfinden und hat diesen Druck, den er am Anfang mit Sicherheit auch hatte. Ganz klar, wenn du als MVP zu Real Madrid wechselst, dann wollen die Fans Tore sehen und zwar von der ersten Minute an. So das hat nicht funktioniert, da hat er sich mit Sicherheit auch ein bisschen, ja, mit sich selbst beschäftigen müssen. Und jetzt ist dieser Knoten geplatzt und jetzt sieht man nicht nur an dem Dreierpark, auch die Spiele davor, wie er wieder mit seiner Schnelligkeit, mit seiner Power, mit seiner Ballsicherheit, mit seiner Torgefährlichkeit einfach Real Madrid ganz wichtige Tore schießt, auch mal den so genannten Türöffner oder macht das 0 zu 1 oder das 1 zu 0 dann eben. Und Lewandowski mit 17 Toren im Moment führende der Torjägerliste, Mbappé jetzt schon nach 15 und er hat sehr spät angefangen zu treffen. Es gibt eine interessante Statistik, die ich euch mitgebracht habe und zwar Mbappé hat mit seinen 15 Toren, die hat er geschafft mit 45 Torschüssen bisher. Das ist der absolute Topwert in der Liga. Auf Platz 2 kommt Lewandowski, der mit 32 Torschüssen 17 Tore gezielt hat. Also ich mein Mbappé trifft mit jedem dritten Schuss und Lewandowski mit jedem zweiten Schuss, schießt aber nicht so oft. Also da kann man sich einiges ablesen, vor allen Dingen, dass halt Real Madrid wirklich viele Abschlüsse dann auch hat. Und ich glaube, Mbappé hat auch ein bisschen profitiert von der kleinen Voramtkrise von Vinícius. Da hat ihm jetzt ein bisschen mehr Spielzeit verschafft und ja, es hat sich einfach ein bisschen besser nach vorne zusammengefunden. Und natürlich musste er auch bei Real des Mittelfelds sich neu sortieren. Der Valverde musste auch erst in die Rolle von Toni Kroos reinrutschen, einen guten Partner neben sich finden, die oft übrigens gewechselt werden. Das ist mal Dani Cevallos, das ist mal Luka Modric, das ist mal Arda Güller, das ist mal Chua Meni, das ist mal Kamar Winger. Und das hat alles ein bisschen gedauert. Dann hatten sie natürlich bei Real auch die Innenverteidiger-Problematik. Kreuzband-Dristan hat jetzt ganz viele Wochen lang einen aus der zweiten Mannschaft, dem Rüdiger, in der Innenverteidigung spielt. Assensio heißt, der hat es eigentlich ganz gut gemacht. Aber klar, das sind halt so Sachen, die bei Real Madrid ein bisschen gebraucht haben. Und jetzt sind sie einfach wieder extrem konstant und vorne halt brandgefährlich einfach. Die müssen gar nicht zaubern wie Barcelona, sondern wenn der Ball dann nach vorne kommt und dann, egal ob es Bellingham ist, der als Zehner unwahrscheinlich Lücken reißt, auch ständig unwahrscheinliche Plätze schafft und der ja nach wie vor mit seiner Schulterverletzung weit weg ist von 100 Prozent, die er eigentlich geben kann. Also Real ist wieder da, wo man sie erwartet, wo man sie kennt. Und ja, es wird schwierig, die noch vom Platz 1 wegzuholen in der Liga.
Eine Zahl von mir noch ganz kurz, weil wir das Thema MVP auch mal schon hier in der Sendung hatten vor ein paar Wochen. Seit Dezember, also wir haben jetzt Ende Januar, hat MVP 13 Tore gemacht.
Stimmt.
Das ist nur, um das mal einzuhornen. Also Wettbewerbsübergreifend logischerweise, also nur so zum Thema, der ist schon in Schuss gekommen, würde ich mal sagen. Und vielleicht ein wichtiger Name noch, Alabaiss auch wieder zurück. Also das glaube ich wird auch noch wahnsinnig wichtig werden für die restliche Saison. Also ich glaube Real stellt sich schon wieder ganz gut auf für die nächsten Monate, die ja typischerweise die Werten der Monate sind.
Und es war relativ überraschend, weil sie haben ja keinen Innenverteidiger nachgeholt, das war ja schon ein bisschen was da auf dem Markt. Und sie haben dann gesagt, ne wir warten das ganze ab, vertrauen tatsächlich auf Alaba, dass er wiederkommt, der ja eigentlich sehr verletzungsanfällig ist, wie wir wissen aus seiner bisherigen Profi-Karriere, was natürlich sehr tragisch ist. Aber jetzt hat er glaube ich drei Spiele in Folge, jeweils so 30 Minuten gemacht, kann mir vorstellen, dass er vielleicht jetzt in der Champions League morgen, heute haben da anfängt. Wir werden sehen, aber auf jeden Fall hat sich der Real ganz gut rausgeholt aus dieser kleinen Krise und auch die Supercopa, die Basa verloren hat, real, Entschuldigung, verloren hat mit 2 zu 5. Das erste Tor von Mbappé war wieder absolut Wahnsinn, dass er sich den Ball aus der eigenen Hälfte holt und einfach durchzieht an allen. Und gut, bei Basa gibt es natürlich noch das Problem mit Czesny oder das Torwartproblem, der ist ein bisschen wild im Moment. Aber auch da, wie gesagt, haben sie sich einigermaßen gefangen. Aber wie gesagt, Real Madrid im Moment, das Team, das man erstmal vom Platz 1 wieder runterholen muss und das wird sehr schwierig werden.
Mbappé, Diskussion bitte nur noch, wenn Uli und Alexi hier mit dabei sind. Und dann gehe ich aber persönlich runter und werde gucken, dass niemand den Router anfasst, während diskutiert wird. Das war ja das letzte Mal das Problem. Tatsächlich war es wirklich jemand, der einfach nur den Router von rechts nach links gestellt hat, der einen Umzugshelfer von mir. Und das hat dafür gesorgt, dass bei mir einmal quasi das komplette Internet neu gestartet ist. Deswegen hatten wir es dann auch nicht on tape. Aber ihr hattet ja viel Spaß nach allem, was ich dann im Nachgespräch so gehört habe. War es ja eine gute Idee. Vielleicht können wir die irgendwann reproduzieren. Also über das Superkörper-Finale könnte man jetzt auch noch mal ganz lange sprechen, aber das ist jetzt auch schon eine Weile her. Lass uns noch kurz, weil wir haben ja auch noch zwei andere liegen. Fabian, aber du wolltest ja auch noch kurz was zu Athletico sagen. Da haben wir natürlich alle mitbekommen, wie Athletico in seiner ganzen Athletico-haftigkeit Leverkusen einmal hat auflaufen lassen, so lange gekitzelt hat, bis sich bei Leverkusen was geregt hat. Und dann haben sie dieses Spiel mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen, schon wieder gegen Leverkusen. Und ja, die wissen glaube ich bis heute noch nicht so genau, was da eigentlich passiert ist. Ist es unfair, wenn ich sage, Athletico macht einfach Diego Simeone, Athletico-Dinge und die machen es halt dieses Jahr wieder sehr gut und deswegen sind sie da oben mit drin?
Das ist so ein bisschen auch mein T-Nur, aber vielleicht sind wir da auch unfair oder bin ich da auch unfair gegenüber der Spielweise. Ich kann, ich mag es nicht. Du hast gesagt kitzeln, für mich ist das provozieren ganz, ganz, ganz nah am Rande der Grenze jedes Mal. Und das Ding gegen Leverkusen war wie gesagt ein Spiegelbild eigentlich für die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit von Atletico Madrid, die es eben normalerweise nicht spielerisch hinbekommen, sondern halt dann auf andere Mittel zugreifen müssen, die dann eben Fouls reklamieren, die keine waren oder wenn sie selbst jemand umtreten zu tun, als hätten sie nur die Luft getroffen. Der Trainer macht das Ganze natürlich auch noch vor. Also es ist wirklich hart und ich glaube Leverkusen hat derbes Lehrgeld gezahlt in diesem Champions League Spiel und in Spanien wird Atletico dafür gelobt, für diese Wettbewerbsfähigkeit sage ich jetzt mal und für diese Spielweise. Ich tue mir da schwer, weil ich finde, man kann aus dieser Mannschaft einfach auch spielerisch mehr rausholen. Aber es ist so, Diego Simeone setzt gerne auf Argentinier, auf Südamerikaner, auf die Mentalität und versucht darüber, Spiele zu gewinnen und schwört seine Mannschaft auch darauf ein. Und die hatten über über das Neujahr einen unglaublichen Lauf. Angefangen schon Ende Oktober, November. Ich glaube, 14 Spiele in Folge haben sie gewonnen. Und da haben sie sich natürlich die Positionen geschaffen, auf der sie jetzt im Moment sind. Vier Punkte hinter Real Madrid in der Champions League eigentlich so gut wie weiter oder sind eigentlich, glaube ich, schon weiter. Genau und haben da mehr oder weniger das Zoll erfüllt. Aber in der Liga Max spielerisch ist das nach wie vor für mich nicht überzeugend. Wir haben vorher gesprochen, Barcelona eigentlich muss Barcelona gewinnen. Sie mogeln am Schluss wieder eins rein. Ich glaube bei Leganes haben sie jetzt einen Elfmeter am Schluss verballert, haben dort Punkte liegen lassen, was eigentlich nicht passieren darf. Jetzt zu Hause am Wochenende gegen Real, auch nur unentschieden. Spielerisch ist es einfach zu derbe und es braucht für Atletico normalerweise dann diese großen Spiele wie jetzt in der Champions League Leverkusen, um dann ihr ganzes Potenzial abzuschöpfen. Und in der Liga reicht es normalerweise halt gegen die kleineren Mannschaften auch mit durchschnittlichen spielerischen Leistungen, weil sie einfach individuell dann einfach die Klasse haben. Ein Grießmann, der immer wieder mal halt vorne den Unterschied macht, Julian Alvarez im Moment, natürlich sehr stark hat man gegen Leverkusen gesehen. Der findet sich da jetzt richtig schön zurecht im Simeone, Cholo, Argentinien, Uruguay, Moloch. Also genau, Atletico Madrid für mich aber nach wie vor spielerisch gehört maximal dann eben auf Platz drei. Und sind aber absolut wettbewerbsfähig, absolut respektabel. Man kann diese Spielweise mögen oder nicht, aber sie liefern. Und ich denke mal, es ist ein harter Prognom als auch in der Champions League, wer auch immer gegen die spielen darf oder muss.
Nur 14 gegen Tore, also die Defensive steht wieder und eben diese Siegesserie, die du angesprochen hast vom 31. Oktober bis zum 18. Januar. Das war die Leganes-Niederlage da 0 zu 1 auswärts. Ich dachte auch, dass du Leganes mitbringst. Das wäre eigentlich so ein typisches Thema für dich. So oft Stolperstein gewesen.
Aber leider nur für die Großen, Maxi. Sie sind ja nur Tabellensechzehntel gegen die Kleinen oder gegen Teams in ihrer Liga. Wenn sie selber ein bisschen raus müssen, dann ist vorbei. Und deswegen hat ja den Trainer, glaube ich, schon bei meinem letzten Mal angesprochen, das war jetzt genug Leganes.
Ja, ja, das stimmt schon. Also Atletico ist wieder Atletico Madrid. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid über die Top 3 in La Liga. Was gibt es denn in der Eredivise, Daniel, was du uns erzählen kannst, was gerade wichtig ist zu wissen?
Ja, ich halte es ja eigentlich so wie Fabian, dass ich gerne kleinere Vereine nehme und präsentiere, sei es Zwolle oder Heran Feyn oder Sittard. Aber ich glaube gerade nach der Champions League und dem 3 zu 0, sag ich liebe Bayern-Fans, von dem 3 zu 0 von Feyenoord, kommen wir eigentlich nicht umhin, um über Feyenoord zu reden, weil das auch schon so operettenhafte Züge angenommen hat, was da um den Trainerpriske los ist. Vielleicht habt ihr es jetzt noch mitbekommen, die dänische Zeitung TIP-Ladis hat vor dem Spiel, vor dem 3 zu 0 gegen Bayern, eigentlich schon gesagt, der ist so gut wie rausgeworfen. Also es war eine Frage der Zeit, wann der Trainerpriske gehen muss und das war eigentlich auch unabhängig von dem Ausgang des Beherrnspiels so angedacht. Und diese Meldung, die in die dänischen Kreisen zuerst gekommen ist, haben dann auch Zeitungen in den Niederlanden adaptiert. Und breit getreten. Und dann kam es, wie wir wissen, alle ganz anders. Und das würde ich gerne mal einordnen, was eigentlich bei Feyenoord gerade los ist mit der Krise, die sie haben. Denn dass das Priske so in der Kritik steht, hat vor allem mit der Punkteausbeute in der Liga zu tun. Die letzten drei Liga-Partien haben sie einen Punkt geholt. Das waren 0-3 gegen PSV, 1-2 gegen Utrecht und unentschieden gegen Willem II. Das ist also absolut nicht der Anspruch, den den Feyenoord hat. Zumal das erklärte Saisonziel von Feyenoord Platz zwei ist mindestens. Die ersten beiden Plätze in der Eredivise sind die, für die man sich für die CE qualifiziert. Das ist das Minimum, was Feyenoord erreichen muss, was der eigene Anspruch ist. Und derzeit sind sie auf vier Neupunkte hinter Ajax, die sich da leise, aber stetig hochgemogelt haben. Und das sorgt natürlich schon für Unmut bei Feyenoord. Und das hat meines Erachtens vor allem mit zwei Sachen zu tun. Einmal sportliche Gründe, die defensive Anfälligkeit. Hab mal geschaut, das ist immer das Schöne, auf die Vorbereitung der Sendung, wenn man tiefer da mal reingeht, fallen eine Sachen auf, die einem gar nicht sonst aufgefallen wären. Die haben wirklich von 19 Partien nur dreimal 0 gespielt. Und das als eigentlich Spitzen-Team in der Eredivisi ist das schon eine Ansage. Und das hat mal in erachtens einfach auch mit Mentalität zu tun. Das sind Tore, die fallen zu einfach. Das sind teilweise individuelle Aussetzer einzelner Spieler. Hat aber auch, um mal das Team so ein bisschen in Schutz zu nehmen, viel mit Rotation und Verletzungsmiserie zu tun. Also die Viererkette, mit der sie spielen, die hat sich in den letzten Spielen immer geändert gefühlt. Weil viele Spieler ausgefallen sind, sowohl im defensiven Mittelfeld, als auch in der Viererkette. Das heißt, du hattest die letzten Wochen, konntest du dich eigentlich kaum hinten einspielen. Was aber, wie ich finde, nicht die gesamte Ausrede sein kann, wenn du dir mehrfach Tore fällst, wo dann eigentlich bei einfacher Flanken in den Dechziger nahe kommen und du dich mit hochspringst und diese ganzen Geschichten, also so einfache Konzentrationsgeschichten, die zu diesen defensiven Anfertigkeiten führen. Und auch wenn Feyenoord offensiv Qualitäten hat und auch regelmäßig Tore erzielt, wenn du dann jedes Spiel immer eine 2, 3 Tore schießen musst, weil du immer auch 1, 2 Tore fängst, ist es auf Dauer auf der Feyenoord schwierig, dann Konstantspiele zu gewinnen. Und das hat Priske auch selbst angesprochen, diese Mentalität, hat gesagt, ja das heilige Feuer, Zitat, heilige Führer, das hat er, das fehlt ihm, das hat er irgendwie nicht gesehen. Und er wirkte auch selbst so ein bisschen ratlos, wie er seinem Team noch helfen kann, was natürlich dann auch immer ein Eingestättenes auch ist. Und das andere Thema, das ist die ganze Geschichte Abscheißesplatzes, was auch schon ein bisschen an den guten alten FC Hollywood erinnert. Nicht ganz so stark, aber schon in die Richtung. Denn es war dann schon so, dass in den Gazetten in den Nierlanden tauchten dann auch schon erste Gerüchte auf, dass sich die Mannschaft und mit Teilen des Trainerteams nicht verstünde. Und es tauchte das Gerücht auf, dass Priske einen Assistenten rauswerfen möchte. Jürgen de Wolf, der war noch unter Slot-Zeiten bei Feyenoord und ist geblieben nach dem Wechsel von Slot. Und jetzt vor einigen Wochen hieß es, dass Priske sich mit ihm überhaupt nicht verträgt und der durchbitte gehen soll. Was wiederum der Klub vehement unterbindet, weil Jürgen de Wolf eine Art Klub-Ikone auch ist. Also ganz viele Gefilde, aber alles nur Gerüchte. Also es ist die Medienlandschaft in den Irlanden, ist da sehr gerne sehr spekulativ und das sorgt natürlich auch für Unruhe und das kann natürlich auch ans Thema getragen werden, diese Unruhe. Und also es war eigentlich alles bereitet für eine Entlassung im Prinzip, wenn man die Medien klaut in dem Fall. Und dann kommt dieses 3 zu 0 gegen Bayern.
Vor allem zu 0 auch noch.
Ja, ja, genau.
Nein Gott FC Bayern, was habt ihr denn wirklich da gemacht? Das ist ja Wahnsinn.
Das war aber nicht Dienst von Feyenoord, sondern eher, würde ich sagen.
Des Forstens unseres Vorwärts.
Ja, der Fingernau-Schluss-Spräche, egal.
Ja, genau. Man muss es einordnen. Es ist schon so, natürlich haben wir damit nicht gerechnet. Das war extrem überraschend und in unserer Oranienfußballgruppe wurde auch noch gewitzelt, wie hochwürstet es eigentlich. Gerade wenn so ein Timber nach ausfällt und gefühlt im Ferienort oder im Mittelfeld angetreten ist, ohne dass er nicht da ist. Und dann hast du aber genau dieses, sag ich mal, heilige Führer, dieses heilige Feuer von was so pristel gefüttert hast du ja gesehen. Das war eigentlich so ein Abend, wie er auch sein muss, wenn du bei Herrn Schlagen willst. Es war eine hervorragende Stimmung. Die Fans haben wirklich die Mannschaft angezündet und die haben sich ja mit allem, was sie haben, reingeworfen. Es war pure Leidenschaft. Klar, ohne den Justin Beilow, den Torwart von Ferienort, der super aufgelinkt war im Tag, fängst du dir die Dinger ohne Aluminium, ich glaube, Bayer hatte mindestens einen Pfosten-Treffer von Napri war es glaube ich im Ende, fängst du dir die Dinger und auch Harry Kane hat da ein, zwei Sachen ausgelassen, die er eigentlich macht. Das sind natürlich, der Druck war unmenschlich, aber dass du dich trotzdem mit der Leidenschaft da reinwürfst und dass du dann aber auch die drei Konter dann auch so zu Ende spielst, das musst du dann auch erstmal machen. Und deswegen würde ich das gar nicht mal so als so unverdient erachten. Und gerade diese Einstellung und diese Leidenschaft, das war gegen Bayern genau das, was in den letzten drei Verleger-Spielen absolut nicht da war. Und insofern hat das einiges verändert, wobei ich aber trotzdem sage, dass das Priske trotzdem noch gehorchig unter Druck steht. Und diese ganze Operette geht jetzt weiter. Nach dem 3-0 gab es dann ein Gespräch zwischen dem politischen Direktor Tegluze und Priske. Und das Ergebnis war ein offizielles Statement. Dazu hat sich dann Feyenoord genütlich gefühlt, das zu publizieren, wo gesagt wird, ja, er ist unser Trainer. Und ja, wir haben dann mal gesprochen und unsere Vision ist jetzt neu geschärft. Und unsere Vision ist jetzt neu geschärft und wir bleiben zusammen und wir gehen weiter. Die kommen Aufgaben an. Also so ein bisschen so PR-Sprech.
Lass uns raten, sie wollen defensiv gut stehen, vorne die Tore machen und immer wieder Talente weiterentwickeln, die sie teuer verkaufen können.
Na ja, so konkret wurden sie nicht. So konkret wurden sie nicht. Es war wirklich rein, unsere Vision wurde noch mal, wir haben unsere Vision neu ausgerichtet und uns beschlossen, weil er zusammen zu arbeiten ist. Es war sehr, sehr allgemein gehalten. Und dann hat sich Priske noch mal hinreißen lassen, jetzt auf der obligatorischen Pressekonferenz von dem CL-Spiel gegen Dill heute. Hat sich hinreißen lassen, noch mal schön auszuteilen. Da ist Priske mal dran. Hat er erstmal den vermeintlichen Maulwurf, der diese Gerüchte an die Presse gebracht hat, noch mal akkreditisiert, was ich auch verstehen kann, und meinte, ja, er denke, er wisse, wer es ist, oder er denke zumindest, dass es eine Person sei, die Feenort sehr nahe stünde und sehr nahe steht, das er natürlich umso schlimmer findet. Es gab dann wiederum Gerüchte, dass sein Berater oder er selbst das gelegt haben soll, was ich aber nicht glaube. Und dann hat er noch mal gegen die Journalistinnen, gegen die Anwesen ausgeteilt nach dem Motto, ja, am Ende des Tages müsst ihr euch ja in die Spiegel schauen können. Und wenn ihr unseriöse Quäl verbreitet, ist das euer Problem. Also er war sehr angefressen und sehr kurz angebunden, was aber auch die Stimmung einfach widerspiegelt. Und als kleiner Ausblick ist hat auch die Frage, wie es weitergeht. Wir haben jetzt das Spiel gegen Lille, da ist nicht ganz so viel Druck drauf, weil durch das 3-0 gegen Bayern hat sich Feyenoord jetzt schon sicher für die Playoffs qualifiziert. Also selbst bei der Nier-Lage hätten sie zumindest die Zwischenrunde erreicht. Aber am Sonntag ist der Klassiker wegen Ajax. Also genau wegen das Team, wo man jetzt schon neun Punkte Rückstand drauf hat. Das Team, was man in der Hinrunde verloren hat, 2-0 gegen. Wenn man da jetzt wieder verliert, sind es dann so ein 12-Punkte Rückstand. Und dann kommt die Diskussion auf jeden Fall wieder zutage. Also es bleibt alles ein Pulverfass und ein heißes Eisen, was zum großen Teil, würde ich sagen, oder zu einem gewissen Teil natürlich auch von den Medien darauf beschworen wird. Aber natürlich, würde ich da sagen, ist da auch ganz viel Wahrheit hinter. Und gerade ist die Frage, ob dieser eine Auftritt gegen Bayern, was ja auch in so einem besonderen Spiel war, im besonderen Rahmen war, so eine Stimmung und so ein Momentum hast du ja auch nicht immer. Ob das über diese vielen blutleeren und unkonsultierten Auftritte in der Liga hinweg schaut, das wird sich zeigen in den kommenden Ligaspielen, vor allem jetzt gegen Ajax.
Ja, vor allem, du siehst in der Champions League immer wieder, es funktioniert. Also du gewinnst auswärts in Girona, auswärts bei Benfica, dann zu Hause gegen Manchester City, dieses 3 zu 3, das haben wir auch damals noch erwähnt. Und jetzt eben dieses 3 zu 0 gegen Bayern. Und das wirft halt umso mehr, wenn du Licht in einem Wettbewerb hast, dann wird der Schatten im anderen Wettbewerb umso dunkler. Jedes Unentschieden, das nicht sein müsste, da bekommst du dann den Eindruck, naja, auf Champions League Bühne hättet ihr das hinbekommen. Wo liegt dann der Unterschied? Das Heilige Feuer scheint der Unterschied zu sein.
Ja, das ist dann wirklich die Frage, die man sich stellen muss, ob, weil an sich können diese ganzen Spiele, auch das 3-3 gegen City ist ein wunderbares Beispiel, so zurückzukommen. Klar, das war auch eine Phase, wo City auch arge Probleme hatte, keine Frage, aber das sind nur Momente, wo du eigentlich weißt, okay, also wenn sie wirklich wollen, wenn da wirklich Mentalität ist, dann können sie es. Ist immer die Gefahr, ich will auf keinen Fall den Spiel, das kann man auch nicht den Willen irgendwie absprechen, was ich will, aber es hat immer schon was zu sagen, in solchen besonderen Nächten, um besonderen Rahmen kommen sie jetzt in ihre Höchstleistungen und sie haben einfach momentan, warum auch immer Satz in Betrieb gibt und können diese Leistungen in der Liga dann nicht abrufen. Can you do it on a rainy Sunday night in Zwolle? Ja, nachher bitte so ein bisschen. Und das können sie anscheinend, haben sie in dieser Saison so ein bisschen, ein bisschen verlernt.
Sprich nicht für die Spieler auf jeden Fall, oder? Wenn man sich Champions League internationale Bühne, da strecken sie sich und recken sie sich und da ist die Motivation riesig und gegen Zwolle eben nicht eigentlich dann ein Kaderding. Mehr vielleicht sogar als Trainer.
Aber das ist die Frage. Qualitativ ist der Kader eigentlich gut. Also daran kann es meines Erachtens nicht liegen. Das würde ich schon attestieren. Insofern bin ich da eigentlich auch dabei, dass man die Einstellung nochmal in diesen Anführungszeichen kleinen Spiele, was aber eigentlich keine kleinen Spiele sind. Und du musst auch in diesen Spielen, das wie ich finde als Privileg, auffassen, dass du Profiliger spielst. Auch wenn es dann nur mal Sitt hat und als Zwolle ist. Aber die sind auch alles große Klubs in meiner Augen.
Daniel, eine Frage noch. Ist Jimenez schon auf dem Weg nach Instanzierer?
Also ich denke, er wird viele Anfragen haben. Also ich denke mal, das ist...
Also ich weiß, Milan probiert alles noch bis für den Wintertransfer. Also Milan ist extrem nah dran. Die warten heute noch ab, was im letzten Champions League-Spiel passiert. Dann wird nochmal ein Angebot drüber kommen. Die sind sich anscheinend auch schon mit dem Spieler einig. So viel zum Thema, dass vielleicht der eine oder andere Spieler halt auch schon die Gedanken vielleicht ein bisschen woanders hat. Also ich bin gespannt, ob Jiménez am Wochenende gegen Ajax noch spielt, weil Milan wird probieren, Orlen zu gehen. Die wollen ihn unverdenken jetzt im Januar.
Also das wäre auf jeden Fall ein Riesenverlust für Feyenoord, weil das ist eigentlich einer der Spieler, der obwohl es aktuell eben nicht so läuft, hat der Spieler noch die Konstanz im Prinzip und trifft halt trotzdem weiterhin und ist für dieses Offensivspiel wirklich von großer Bedeutung tatsächlich.
Das ist die Definition von Exzellenz oder kann eine Definition von Exzellenz sein. Sehr gute Leistungen bringen viele Leistungssportler, aber unter ein gewisses sehr hohes Niveau nie zu fallen. Das schaffen tatsächlich nur sehr, sehr wenige, weil da muss alles zusammenkommen. Also wir sehen uns an, was mit Jimenez passiert und wir blicken dann jetzt auch mal in die Serie A. Und ich finde es ganz interessant, wie wir vorhin vor 20 Minuten über ein Team gesprochen haben, mit 35 Toren und 14 kassierten Toren. Da haben wir gesagt, boah, Atletico, sie machen wieder ihr Ding und eigentlich müssten die eher dritter sein als zweiter. Jetzt wollen wir sprechen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, Christian, über ein Team mit 37 Toren und 15 kassierten Toren. Aber Napoli führt die Tabelle souverän an. Wo sind die Unterschiede?
Ja, und das ist schön, dass es eben nicht immer nur um Zahlen geht, sondern dass wir das auch mal ein bisschen beschreiben können. Zum Einstieg kurz von meiner Seite. Ich bin direkt vom Zahnarzt hier angereist. Ich hoffe meine noch betäubte Lippe lasst mich nicht im Stich, aber ich gebe alles. Ja, wir müssen ganz unbedingt über Napoli reden. Napoli ist Tabellenführer. Genau, Napoli hat gerade Juve geschlagen, hat die Woche zuvor Atalanta auswärts geschlagen, hat jetzt sieben Siege in Folge. Und dann kommen wir jetzt eben beim Punkt. Wunderbar. Danke für deine Einleitung, Max. Da denken wahrscheinlich viele noch, ach Napoli, Antonio Conte, klar, die stehen ja hinten, die Null steht und dann gibt es halt vielleicht mal einen langen Ball auf Lukaku und dann gibt es vielleicht mal ein Eckballtor und dann gewinnt halt Napoli viele Spiele. Das war vielleicht zu Beginn der Saison wirklich teilweise so, da hat Napoli wirklich sehr viele knappe Spiele, gewonnen auch oft 1-0, wo es spielerisch jetzt noch nicht sehr verrauschend war, aber und jetzt kommt es aber seit einigen Wochen und gerade eben diese sieben Siege jetzt da, zeigt sich Napoli von der ganz anderen Seite. Also Napoli hat sich unter Konter spielerisch, ich hätte es auch nicht gedacht, dass es so schnell passiert, aber extrem stark weiterentwickelt. Also die letzten Spiele, wenn man sich auch anschaut, eben drei Tore aus, wenn wir jetzt nur auf das Offensive schauen, weil sie eben immer mal hieß, ah ja, Napoli braucht halt wenig, weil sie so gut stehen. Drei Auswärtstore in Bergamo, drei Auswärtstore in Florenz, haben sie 3-0 gewonnen im Januar, drei Tore in Udine, zwei gegen Juve, zwei gegen Hellas. Also Napoli kreiert wahnsinnig viel mehr und das liegt daran, deswegen müssen wir jetzt, man kann viel über Napoli sprechen, wir könnten jetzt über Angizar sprechen, der herausragend ist seit Wochen, der vielleicht sogar besser ist als in der Meistersaison und das Ballett, was jetzt ja auch schon keine einfache Aufgabe war, aber also wirklich herausragend. Aber ich für mich lande absolut bei Antonio Conte, weil er eben Antonio Conte immer so ein bisschen vorgeworfen wurde. Ja gut, man kennt ja den Conte Fußball hier 352 und hinten werden die Räume zugemacht und dann ist halt Athletik und dann passiert vorne vielleicht was, weil er ja auch gute Einzelspieler hat. Und Conte macht jetzt wirklich allein schon in diesen ersten sechs Monaten in Neapel wirklich, finde ich, wenn man seine ganze Karriere anschaut, eine beeindruckende Metamorphose. Legt da hin, weil eben gerade dieses 352, das war eigentlich immer dieses charakteristische Conte-Ding, das ihn ja seit Juwe-Zeiten über Chelsea, bei Inter eigentlich immer begleitet hat quasi. Also Conte-3er-Kette-5er-Kette gegen den Ball, war wahnsinnig schwer zu knacken. Die Außenspieler, die Schienenspieler, wie es hier mittlerweile ja heißen, laufen wie Leichtathleten rauf und runter. Also das war ja vielleicht, erinnert sich noch ein paar Anfangszeiten, bei Juwe war das zum Beispiel Stefan Lichtsteiner, der Schweizer Nationalspieler. Dann bei Chelsea-Zeiten, als er sie zur Meisterschaft geführt hat, war Mikto Boses so einer, der da auf außen rauf und nieder marschiert ist. Bei Inter-Zeiten war es Hakimi quasi. Also das war eigentlich der Fußball, für den Antonio Conte stand. Und in Neapel hat er ja auch am Anfang der Saison mit so einem 3-5-2 angefangen, genau sein typisches Schema gebracht. Aber eben, er hat sich in Neapel jetzt erst weggekommen von dem Schema. Er ist erst hin zu so einem 4-2-2-2. Und jetzt ist es mittlerweile und jetzt hat er seine Mischung gefunden und die wird er bis zum Ende durchziehen. Jetzt ist es ein 4-3-3. Und gerade anhand der Außenverteidiger, finde ich, kann man diese Metamorphose am besten beschreiben, weil die Außenverteidiger, die Lorenzo rechts und Olivera links, eigentlich gar nicht mehr über außen kommen, sondern wahnsinnig in das Zentrum auch mit reinrücken. Extrem wichtig im Spielaufbau sind das Zentrum verdichten, da Anspielstationen bieten, Gegner auf sich ziehen. Und sozusagen das ganze Spiel einfach von Konte wahnsinnig weiterentwickelt hat. Mcdominay und Anguissard spielen da eine extrem wichtige Rolle, die das Zentrum eben auch befüllen. Dann hast du Lukaku, der Spieler schlechthin von Konte logischerweise, der wahnsinnig gut als Wandspieler agiert, der aber eben mehr jetzt auch ist als nur ein Wandspieler, sondern der auch wirklich im letzten Drittel oft derjenige auch ist, der den letzten Pass spielt, also die Bälle nicht nur prallen lässt, sondern wirklich auch genau diese Räume erst mal öffnet, in die den Anguissa und Mcdominay und teilweise auch die Lorenzer reinstossen, ist mittlerweile zum Beispiel Lukaku der zweitbeste Vorlagengeber der Serie A auch. Also nur noch tabarisch immer noch auf Platz 1, Nummer 2 mittlerweile Lukaku mit sieben Vorlagen. Also da sieht man auch, dass die Rolle von Lukaku, klar Lukaku ist nicht mehr der von vor zwei, drei Jahren, hat nicht mehr diese Explosivität. Aber im Spiel von Konter ist ja immer noch elementar wichtig. Dann hast du mit Neres auf links, du hast ja quasi deinen eigenen Quaratzkelie-Nachfolger kreiert, schon während der Saison. Weil das Thema Quaratzkelie müssen wir uns logischerweise auch nochmal ansprechen. Es ist schon ungewöhnlich, dass im Januar so ein Transfer dieser Größenordnung über die Bühne geht. Also ich hätte eher gedacht, dass das dann im Sommer passiert. Aber die Quaratzkelier-Enthorage hat da halt eindeutig schon seit Monaten ganz stark darauf hingearbeitet. Im Sommer konnte er noch sein Veto einlegen, weil er war ja klar, als er nach Nerpel kam, hat er gesagt, ich komme, aber wenn ich komme, bleiben die Lorenzer und Quaratzkelier. Also da gab es kein Wegkommen. Und jetzt aber haben sie halt alle verstanden, dass sie das nicht abwenden können, weil ich nenne mal kurz eine Zahl, die das vielleicht ganz gut erklärt, weil Quaratzkelier jetzt in Paris ungefähr sechsmal so viel verdient wie in Nerpel. Also in Nerpel hat er 1,5, 1,6 Netto noch verdient und in Paris sind es jetzt 9 oder 10 Netto. Dann muss man auch sagen, gut, das sind gute Argumente, glaube ich. Da ist dem schwer, sich entgegenzutreten. Aber Konte, finde ich, hat auch das wahnsinnig gut moderiert, kommunikativ. Also er hat im Wind, er hat keinen Vorwurf von Quaratzkelier gemacht, jetzt als er ging. Er hat auch keinen Vorwurf von dem Verein gemacht, sondern er hat so das Scheinwerferlicht auf sich gezogen, hat gemeint, ich bin enttäuscht von mir, dass ich es nicht geschafft habe, Quaratzkelier sozusagen vom vom Bleiben zu überzeugen. Das finde ich, hat er sehr clever gemacht, weil ihm das logischerweise niemand den Neapel vorwirft, aber weil er das halt sehr smart gemacht hat, weil er eben nicht sozusagen dem Verein jetzt vorwirft quasi zwischen den Zeilen, oh ihr habt mir eine meiner wichtigsten Spieler verkauft und auf Quaratzkelia hat er auch sehr elegant, ist er gar nicht böse quasi eingegangen. Also ich finde das hat er kommunikativ super gemacht und wie gesagt spielerisch, er hat sich näheres schon, denn die Wochen davor hat Neres auch schon für Quaratzelia gespielt. Also seit Dezember spielt Neres, Neres spielt überragend, er hat ihn erst von rechts auf links heben gezogen, macht im Prinzip den Quaratzelia, weil konnte er sicherlich im Dezember wahrscheinlich schon gespürt, in welche Richtung das bei Quaratzelia geht und dementsprechend finde ich das halt auch eine ganz starke Trainerleistung, wenn du dir quasi intern aus deinem Kader schon mal was erarbeitest, was dann einen deiner wichtigsten Spieler sozusagen, dass du dir den intern ersetzen kannst und dementsprechend es spricht einfach wahnsinnig viel für Napoli, wahnsinnig viel für Konter, wie was sie da jetzt in den letzten Wochen wirklich auch spielerisch weiterentwickelt haben.
Also das sieht von der Tabellenkonstellation ja wirklich sehr, sehr eindeutig aus und vor allem, weil man diese direkten Duelle gewonnen hat. Also die ganze Zeit habe ich hier immer das Serie-A-Segment damit eingeleitet, dass ich gesagt habe, drei Punkte, so wie viele Vereine liegen innerhalb dieser drei Punkte, mal waren es vier, mal waren es fünf, zwischendurch sogar sechs. Und das hat sich jetzt eben ein bisschen aufgesplittet, weil Napoli da einfach eben, du hast es ja schon angesprochen, die entscheidenden Spiele gewonnen hat. Jetzt haben wir aber ja schon häufiger das Thema nachhaltiger Erfolg von Konter Teams gehabt. Ich will jetzt nicht unken und du sollst auch nicht spekulieren, aber hast du das Gefühl, weil du jetzt gemeint hast, es hat sich ja sonst schon was verändert mit eben, also die Pragmatik scheint ein bisschen zurückgegangen zu sein, mit eben Umständungen auf 4-3-3 und so weiter und so fort. Hast du einen Eindruck, dass das auch ein nachhaltiger Erfolg sein könnte jetzt bei Napoli? Oder ist es unserius darüber jetzt zu sprechen?
Ja, also ich kann logisch nicht in die Glaskugel blicken. Das ist vielleicht dann mal auch ein, glaube ich, ein größeres Thema, weil ich finde auch, ich habe mich jetzt wirklich viel auch mit Conti beschäftigt in den letzten Wochen, weil es mich auch einfach interessiert hat. Bin auch auf seine Zeiten früher eingegangen und ich finde, aber das wie gesagt ist ein großes Thema. Das kann man dann ja vielleicht mal im Mai, wenn vielleicht in Neapel wieder was passiert, was in Neapel immer ganz besondere Emotionen hervorruft, nennen wir es mal so, kann man da ja vielleicht mal in Ruhe sprechen. Also ich weiß nicht logischerweise, wie es sich konnte nächstes Jahr in den nächsten Jahren präsentieren wird, aber ich habe ein Gefühl, dass er schon gerade, das merkt man auch jetzt, es kamen zuletzt von Gasperini und von Thiago Motta auch so, also von direkten Konkurrenten, so kleine Spitzen auch so vom Wegen. Thiago Motta zum Beispiel auch auf der Pressekonferenz vor dem Spiel gemeint, ja gut, Napoli steht eben tief hinten drin und kontert. Und ich dachte mir so, wow, das ist nicht clever von euch, weil es einfach auch nicht mehr stimmt. Es ist, Napoli Konter hat sich wirklich extrem weiterentwickelt in dieser Saison. Und ich, das sind nur eine Gefühlsache von mir logischerweise, die kann ich nicht mit Daten belegen, aber vielleicht ist auch ein Punkt gekommen, wo, weil Konter ja auch dieser Ruf nachhängt, immer eben so der Wanderer zu sein, der irgendwo hinkommt, dann baut er was Krasses auf, aber nach zwei, drei Jahren ist einfach die Luft raus. Das hat seine Geschichte bisher absolut bisher so hergegeben, gar keine Frage, das steht so faktisch. Aber vielleicht ist er mittlerweile, er hat jetzt auch ein gewisses Alter, er ist jetzt viel rumgekommen, er ist jetzt in Neapel, Achtung, Antonio kommt aus Lecce, also aus Süditalien. Und Neapel ist sicherlich jetzt der Ort, der ihm am nächsten ist auch von seiner Art und Weise. Vielleicht ist jetzt auch eine Zeit gekommen, das konnte mehr hinterlassen möchte, als nur dieses, okay, ich nehm eine Mannschaft, baue sie krass wieder hin und laufe dann nach zwei Jahren weg wieder quasi. Also das wie gesagt ist jetzt nur ein Gefühl von mir, das kann ich logischerweise nicht belegen. Aber Fakt ist, dass das jetzt schon spielerisch wirklich, also ich bin mir sicher, wenn all die Sachen, die ich jetzt zumindest nur angerissen habe, da könnte man noch taktisch viel mehr ins Detail gehen, ist ja klar. Wenn das ein Thiago Motta gemacht hätte oder ein Gasparini oder ein anderer Trainer, dann würden alle extrem schwärmen. Schau mal an, krass weiterentwickelt. Und bei Konte ist es so ein bisschen, ja gut, es ist halt immer noch Konte. Aber ich finde, es ist wirklich eine krasse Weiterentwicklung. Weil schaut euch ein Napoli-Spiel mal an. Das ist wirklich, also allein schaut euch an, wo die Lorenz und Olivera als Außenverteidiger, was die für ein Radius haben, was die für eine Heatmap haben, die sind auf der Doppel-Sex, die rücken auf zu Lobotka ein. Das sind alles so Geschichten, die bei anderen Namen, bei europäischen Trainern wahnsinnig hervorgehoben worden wären. Und bei Konte ist es halt immer noch so ein bisschen, ja gut, wisst ihr selbst, Konte und so. Und dementsprechend finde ich, zeigt er jetzt wirklich in diesen Monaten, dass er die Zeit, die er nach seiner Tottenheim-Zeit hatte, hatte er ein Jahr lang Zeit und er hat auch immer gesagt, er wird sich weiterentwickeln, er wird studieren, er war viel zu Gast bei anderen Trainer. Und es scheint so aus, als ob er diese Zeit wirklich genutzt hätte und das nicht einfach nur so zu reden waren. Und deswegen, ja, letzter Satz dazu. Der riesen Vorteil von Napoli bleibt ja weiterhin, auf den habe ich ja schon im Sommer hingewiesen. Sie haben keine Doppelbelastung. Napoli hat noch genau 16 Spiele, die kann er von Sonntag bis Sonntag planen. Das bringt logisch riesen Vorteil in Sachen Intensität mit, keine Frage. Aber ich finde, Konter nutzt die Zeit jetzt unter der Woche auch, von Montag bis Freitag, wahnsinnig gut, um sich fußballerisch weiterzuentwickeln. Und dementsprechend ist es wirklich beeindruckend. Zwei letzte Zahlen noch. Napoli hat gleich viele Punkte in der Liga wie Liverpool. Und ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig, dass wenn es eine Mannschaft bisher in dieser Saison gibt, europäisch, die herausragt, dann ist es Liverpool zwischen Liga und Champions League, oder? Ich glaube, und nur zur Einordnung, Napoli hat gleich viele Punkte geholt wie Liverpool in der Premier League und Napoli hat jetzt eben diesen Run, diesen sieben Siege. Und wie du richtig sagst, Max, aus dem Vielkampf ist jetzt im Prinzip ein zweieinhalb Kampf geworden, weil Inter und Napoli, die werden sich matchen. Inter kann das logischerweise mitgehen. Und ich sag, ich wird Atalanta auch immer noch nicht komplett rausnehmen. Es sind zwar sieben Punkte hinten, das ist viel, aber ich trau Atalanta auch weiterhin zu, dass die wieder mal fünf, sechs Spiele hintereinander gewinnen in der Liga und dann vielleicht zwei, drei Punkte näher rankommen. Also im Großen und Ganzen schaut es jetzt schon nach einem Zweikampf von Inter und Napoli aus, aber es ist wirklich beeindruckend, wie gesagt, wie Napoli mittlerweile auch Fußball spielt. Und eben das Allerletzte noch, sorry, die Physis, die Athletik dieser Mannschaft ist wirklich herausragend. Also ich hatte jetzt auch, ich hab mit Mario, wir haben am Wochenende das Jubelspiel gemacht. Das war eine gute erste Halbzeit von Juwe, da führt Juwe auch 1-0, ist okay, also was heißt ist okay, du führst auswärts beim Tabellenführer, gute Leistung. Und in der zweiten Hälfte hat Napoli die aufgefressen. Juwe hatte keinen einzigen Torabschluss mehr, keinen einzigen in 45 Minuten und hatte drei Ballaktionen mit Napoli. In der zweiten Hälfte. Und das war die erste Niederlage von Juwe, also in der Liga in dieser Saison. Und das musst du mit Juwe schon erstmal machen. Und wie gesagt, die Woche davor gegen Atalanta auswärtsgewonnen und allein, also in der Luft oder nach Standards als Gegner, du hast in der Luft zu verteidigen Lukaku, Anguissa, McTominay, Rachmani. Das sind vier elitäre Kopfballspieler, die bringen Wucht mit, die bringen Athletik mit. Jetzt kommt Bon Giorno auch noch zurück, der seit Wochen verletzt gefehlt hat. Der Abwehrchef, den haben sie auch total aufgefangen, haben ohne ihn jetzt gewonnen sechsmal in Folge. Der kommt auch noch mal zurück. Also die Athletik, die Intensität, die diese Mannschaft mitbringt, die belebt dann sozusagen, konnte halt noch mal mehr unter der Woche logischerweise keiner machen, weil er nicht wie Juve, Inter, Milan, Atalanta und alle anderen halt am Dienstag oder Mittwoch noch irgendwo in Europa rumreisen muss, sondern weil er von Montag bis Freitag diese Intensität halt hochhält. Das ist wirklich beeindruckend.
Christian, du hast den McTominay jetzt ein paar Mal angesprochen, würde mich interessieren, wie der sich im italienischen Fußball zurechtfindet, weil bei Atletico Madrid gibt es mit Conor Gallagher die andere Situation, der kommt gar nicht klar mit dem spanischen Fußball und spielt, kriegt nur Kurzeinsätze und McTominay glaube ich ist schon gesetzt, oder?
Ist großartig. Also ich muss sagen, auch da vielleicht auch noch mal einen Satz zu Konter. Im Sommer Konter war im Prinzip der, der den Transfermarkt bei Napoli gemacht hat. Also Napoli, Junto ist ja schon das zweite Jahr nicht mehr da, der große Architekt der Meistermannschaft. Jetzt ist ein relativ junger Sportdirektor da, Mana heißt der, aber als Konter kam, hat er die Ansagen gemacht, wie der möchte. Er hat sie bekommen und alle funktionieren. Lukaku funktioniert, Bon giorno, großartig, näherisch funktioniert. Und jetzt landen wir bei McTominay, also überragender Impact, den er hat. Also ich glaube Napoli hat 27 Millionen für den ausgegeben, wieder mal ein typischer United-Transfer. Ich habe auch mal mit Ueli gesprochen, er hat gemeint, dass vielleicht der einzige Spieler, den United nicht hätte verkaufen sollen, weil es der einzige ist, dem auch sehr viel am Verein liegt, den geben sie ab. Sehr gut. Muss man halt United fragen. Aber sensationell. Also der bringt eben genau die Physis mit, ist dominant, hat jetzt glaube ich fünf Tore auch schon er und Angus Sarum zusammen zehn Tore geschossen als Achter. Also die haben jetzt schon zehn Tore von Achtern. Brutale physische Präsenz ist glaube ich der laufstärkste Spieler der Liga, der läuft im Schnitt immer zwölf Kilometer pro Spiel oder mehr, torgefährlich und für den hat er im Prinzip auch sein ganzes System umgestellt. Also als Mcdominie da war, als er den eingebaut hat, ist er weg vom 352 und hin auf dieses 4222 oder jetzt 433. Am Anfang hat Mcdominie oft sogar zweite Spitze neben Lukaku gespielt, ist aus dem Mittelfeld mit vorgerückt und jetzt ist er klassischer Achter, Lobotka macht die sechs und Angus Sarum und Mcdominie marschieren. Es ist wirklich beeindruckend. Also schade, dass wir die, ich würde die so gerne dieses Jahr gegen europäisches Top Team in der Champions League sehen. Sehen wir nicht und ist auch die Erklärung, warum die dieses Jahr so gut sind, weil sie eben nicht die Doppelbelastung haben. Nächstes Jahr müssen sie das dann beweisen. Aber ich würde sie im Moment echt gerne sehen, weil sie eine unfassbar dominante und sehr, sehr gut aufeinander abgestimmte Mannschaft sind.
Am 2. März kommt es zum Aufeinandertreffen mit Inter. Da kann man auf jeden Fall den Blick schon mal drauf werfen. Dann lasst uns mal noch kurz in unsere kürzeren Themen rein, unsere kurzen Geschichten aus den Ligen reinspringen, bevor ich da noch ein Thema mitgebracht habe. Relativ spontan. Wir schaffen es ganz gut, die Zeit zu füllen, habe ich das Gefühl. Aber gut, ist ja auch schön mal, sich ein bisschen Zeit nehmen zu können. Zudritt Fabian, was gibt es denn noch an kleineren Geschichten aus der spanischen Liga zu berichten?
Ja, ich habe noch einen Ansagen hier mitgebracht und zwar den Trainer von Rayo Vallecano, die sich da im Moment auf Platz 7 vorgemogelt haben. Was zum anderen oder zum einen natürlich auch daran liegt, dass die anderen Teams ein bisschen schwächeln, die so ein bisschen eigentlich eher nach Europa schielen sollen, ob das jetzt Mallorca ist oder Bettis oder Real Sociedad. Genau, aber die haben einen sehr interessanten Trainer mit Inigo Perez, der 37 erst ist, vor zwei Jahren noch gespielt hat und der im Winter, also der es sowieso schon mal nicht einfach hat bei Rayo, die haben einen sehr kuriosen Präsidenten, Raúl Martín-Prés, der ist sehr eigenwillig und Rayo Vallecano ja auch ein sehr spezieller Verein. Und die hatten ja unter anderem die Personale James im Sommer geholt und haben ihn eigentlich bis auf paar Kurzeinsätze gar nicht spielen lassen, haben ihn jetzt im Winter wieder vom Hof gejagt und Inigo Perez hat es ein bisschen ähnlich verkauft, wie konnte die Geschichte mit dem Abgang so von wegen ja, er gibt sich als Trainer die Schuld, dass er Hammes nicht hat besser einbauen können. Ähnliches ist ihm auch nicht gelungen in Anführungszeichen mit Raúl de Tomás, der eigentlich einer der besten spanischen Torhäger ist und bei Rayo auch nicht spielt. Also der ist ziemlich krass, was die Aufstellung anbelangt, was sein Kader anbelangt, wenn da jemand dabei ist, der nicht ins Gefüge passt oder der sich nicht einfügt, dann spielt der nicht. Und Rayo ist jetzt nicht so, dass die von talentierten Spielern ausflippen würden, sondern da war ein James oder ein Raúl de Tomás, würden schon herausstechen und die hat er beide eben nicht einbauen können, so hat es er zumindest formuliert und ist trotzdem im Moment Tabellen-Siebter. Und dementsprechend muss ich sagen, macht er echt einen super Job. Wie gesagt, 37 Jahre alt, Inigo Pérez hat gespielt oder ist Basket-Kompetent, Athletic Bilbao hat da lange gespielt, später noch bei Osasuna. Und ja, ist einer der interessanteren Trainer im Moment im spanischen Markt, der vielleicht nächstes Jahr nicht mehr bei Rayo trainieren wird.
Hm, buckmarken wir uns für mein letztes Thema. Deines Foreshadowing. Daniel, welche kleine Geschichte hast du uns noch mitgebracht aus der Eredivisie?
Ich hab auch einen Anzang Hevo, der meines Erachtens viel zu oft unter dem Radar ist. Das ist nämlich Wein Flamingo von PSV Eindhoven. Es ist halt immer schwierig, für Verteidiger bei PSV wirklich rauszustechen, weil es vor allem um die Offensive geht bei PSV, wenn wir an De Jong, an Pepe, an Tilmen, bei Kajoko denken. Das ist dann immer schwierig für Verteidiger, da würde ich rauszustechen, aber gerade Wein Flamingo bringt eigentlich mit seinen jungen Jahren, 22 Jahren, eigentlich alles mit, um künftig auch in einer größeren International League, Family League, Liga, Serie A zu spielen. Der S22 hat aber alle Spiele bestritten in der Startelf, also sowohl Z-Benz League, als auch in der Redivisie. Hat 91% Passquote in der Liga in den 20 Spielen. Und ist, hat eigentlich wirklich, der ist unglaublich dynamisch und laufstark, gewinnt gute 1-2, 1-2, alle und vor allem sind das Spieleröffnungspässe, das ist wirklich à la bonheur, würde ich sagen. Also das würde Spaß zuzuschauen, wie er hinten mit diesen jungen Jahren schon die Defensive ordnet und auch wirklich tolle eröffnende Pässe an den Mann bringt. Das ist mir ein Anliegen, das noch mal zu betonen, dass es eben nicht runtergeht. Er hatte jetzt in der Champions League gegen Roter Stern Belgrad auch glatt rot gesehen, deswegen, was mir nun mal umso wichtiger herauszuheben, dass es eigentlich nicht der Fall ist, dass er das häufiger macht, sondern dass er eigentlich echt ein Top ist und der für die Struktur, für das Aufbauspiel vom PSV eigentlich der Mann ist, der da hinten die Sachen regelt. Er kam von Utrecht für, ich glaub, 6 Millionen, also hat auch Schlange gerne gekostet, hat seinen Marktwert innerhalb eines Jahres schon echt vervielfacht. Der war vor drei bis vier Millionen wert, dort hat es ja markt.de vergangenes Jahr, jetzt bei 16 Millionen schon und ich glaube, da ist auch noch nicht das Ende der Fahnenstange erreicht. Und gerade auch noch mal die Champions League-Abende, da hat er echt noch mal ausgestochen gegen Sporting zum Beispiel, da hat Victor Kyokeres kein Land gesehen gegen ihn. Der war wirklich komplett in der Tasche, vielleicht mal gesteckt worden. Und genau, das ist so ein kleiner Anzang, der halt aufgrund der Offensivkraft von PSV oft nicht so wahrgenommen wird, der aber sehr wichtig ist.
Sehr schön. Ryan Flamingo hat auch einen wunderbaren Namen, den kann man sich wundern. Hilft natürlich noch mit dazu. Christian, hast du uns auch einen wunderbaren Namen mitgebracht?
Ja, ich hab, wir sollten mal Bologna wieder mal kurz anreisen, weil Bologna letztes Jahr ja groß an wo geben, Thiago Motta und alle haben Bologna gefeiert. Und jetzt ist es logisch ein bisschen ruhiger geworden, weil Thiago Motta nicht mehr da ist, weil Calafiori nicht mehr da ist, weil Zirk C nicht mehr da ist. Aber Bologna spielt auch dieses Jahr wieder eine sehr, sehr starke Saison. Und da wollte ich es kurz mal mitnehmen, weil das ja nicht unbedingt zu erwarten war. Sie haben dieses Jahr die Doppelbelastung mit Champions League zum ersten Mal eben. Haben da logischerweise waren relativ früh aus dem Rennen schon, weil sie auch, finde ich, ein schweres Programm hatten, hatten auswärts Liverpool, hatten auswärts Ersten Villa, auswärts Benfica, aber haben jetzt gegen Dortmund, es war wirklich ein emotionaler Moment. Es war das erste, der erste Sieg in der, logisch hieß sie damals noch nicht Champions League, sondern Kap der Landesmeister seit über 60 Jahren. Also die Rückkehr von Bologna war wirklich eine historische. Und die haben das wirklich gefeiert. Also dieses Spiel auch, wie sie es angegangen sind. Und klar ist mir schon klar, dass Dortmund momentan nicht in der großartigsten Verfassung ist. Aber musst du als Bologna dann halt doch erst mal schlagen. Und vor allen Dingen, sie haben sie auch so geschlagen. Und deswegen wollte ich jetzt eben auch drauf zurückkommen. Nämlich mit Mitteln, die sie extrem auszeichnen. Nämlich ein extrem gutes Gegenpressing und Pressing. Also das 2-1, das entscheidende Tor gegen Dortmund, fällt eben durch so einen hohen Ballgewinn. Und das ist wirklich charakteristik pur von Vincenzo Italiano, nämlich dem neuen Trainer, der im Sommer übernommen hat, der der Fußballer Fiorentina war, der die Fiorentina zweimal ins Conference League Finale geführt hat. Und der jetzt so ein bisschen unterm Radar quasi da wirklich eine richtig gute Arbeit macht. Denn Bologna ist auch dieses Jahr wieder mitten im Rennen um die Champions League Quali. Also um Platz 4, sind nur knapp hinter Juve, das ist ein sehr enges Rennen. Also vom engen Meisterschaftsrennen hat sich es jetzt zu einem sehr engen Rennen um Platz 4 quasi entwickelt, wo wirklich viele Mannschaften drin ist. Und Bologna ist da eben auch drin, weil sie sich extrem gefangen haben, die haben seit August in der Liga nur zwei Spiele verloren und die zwei Spiele waren sie jeweils in Unterzahl, weil sie teilweise auch wirklich blöde rote Karte gefangen haben. Haben zuletzt 2-2 in San Siro gegen Inter gespielt, 2-2 gegen Juve und wirklich gerade in den Spielen, da waren die teilweise, also gegen Juve waren sie besser vor einigen Wochen in Turin, da gleicht Juve in der Nachspielzeit aus. Und gegen Inter jetzt, was ja logischerweise noch mal ein anderes Niveau ist, haben die auf Augenhöhe mit Inter in San Siro gespielt und auch völlig zur rechten 2-2 geholt. Und eben deswegen wollte ich den einen Punkt, den ich anbringen wollte, ist wirklich dieses Pressing und Gegenpressing ist sensationell. Ich hab den PPDA-Wert mitgebracht zur Erklärung. Das ist ja ein statistischer Wert eben, der angibt, also wie viele Pässe lasse ich einer gegnerischen Mannschaft zu, bevor ich sozusagen eine Defensivaktion starte. Also das ist ein Indikator dafür, wenn es wenig Pässe sind, dass ich eben früh drauf gehe, dass ich einfach früh den Gegner unter Druck setze. Und Polonia hat mit Abstand, mit großem Abstand den besten PPDA-Wert in der Serie A. Und ich habe mir jetzt die Mühe gemacht, alle Top-League auch zu vergleichen. In Europa gibt es nur eine Mannschaft, die einen noch besseren Wert hat und das ist, sie ist heute hier auch anwesend, Fabian. Schauen wir mal in der Hand.
Barca?
Ja, das ist Barca. Genau. Es ist Barca und wissen wir ja auch bei Barca, die hohe Kette haben wir jetzt schon gesehen unter Flick. Also und das ist schon, finde ich, sehr beeindruckend, wenn dann Polonia in den Ligen mitspielt. Also quasi höhere Werte als Bayern, höherer PPDA-Wert als Bayern, höher als City, Liverpool, Inter als die anderen Großen. Und das zeigt, dass das gegen die extrem unangenehm ist, weil sie dich früh anlaufen, weil sie dich intensiv anlaufen und weil sie dementsprechend dann auch halt immer wieder Ballgewinne in gefährlichen Zonen haben und dann halt eben kurzen Weg zum Tor haben. Und da dann auch wirklich Spielertypen haben, gerade auf außen ganz starke 1 gegen 1 Spieler. Du hast N'Doye, den Schweizer Nationalspieler. Du hast Orsolini, die genau der Spielertyp sind. Der Ball nach Ballgewinn kommt dann auf außen und dann ist einer von den Dribbler von den 1 gegen 1 und dann geht es vertikal Richtung Tor. Sehr gefährlich, machen Riesenspaß und wie gesagt finde ich wirklich erwähnenswert, weil das ja eine Mannschaft ist, die ja nicht historisch gewohnt ist, Doppelbelastung zu haben. Also für Bologna ist das ja eine Ausnahmesituation, sage ich mal Sonntag, Mittwoch, Samstag, Dienstag zu spielen. Und dementsprechend finde ich, muss man es noch höher einschätzen, dass sie das auch noch mit der Champions League Belastung jetzt auch in der Liga wieder so bringen, dass sie wieder im Rennen um Platz 4 sind und zum gleichen Zeitpunkt, zum vorigen Jahr unter Thiago Motta, auch gleich viele Punkte haben. Also sie stehen im Prinzip gleich gut da wie letztes Jahr, haben aber eben die Champions League auch noch mit dabei. Und ein letzter Ding, extrem spannender Spieler, einer dieser offensiven Außen, das ist ein junger Argentinier, Benjamin Dominguez heißt der, schaut euch den mal an, sensationell. Also ganz, ganz kleiner, wendliger, wusliger, ja, einer glaube ich, den man sehr gerne zuschaut. Hat jetzt auch schon zwei, drei Tore gemacht, den haben sie auch so hervorgezaubert. Ich glaube, von dem wird auch noch viel zu hören sein. Wirklich großartiger 1 gegen 1-Spieler, den hältst du schwer, der bringt wahnsinnig viel Kreativität mit. Und ja, so ein bisschen das Gesicht vielleicht des neuen Bologna.
Das neue Bologna. Borussia Dortmund hat es gerade erst erfahren, auf den BVB kommen wir gleich nochmal. Weiteres Vorschreitwing. Jetzt aber nochmal eine Speed-Runde. Wobei Fabian, bei deinem Thema wird es schwierig da durchzusprinten. Ich hab's vorhin schonmal angesprochen. Wir sprechen über Dani Olmo, der kurz mal nicht registriert werden durfte und für den dann eine Ausnahmeregel gefunden wurde, damit er jetzt doch spielen darf.
Eine Ausnahmeregel der spanischen Regierung eigentlich, muss man sagen, vom spanischen Sportrat. Also da, Fußball ist Wahnsinn und in Spanien ist es auch sehr politisch. Also ganz kurz zum Einordner. Dani Olmo wurde im Sommer von Red Bull Leipzig geholt und war dann ganz lange nicht spielberechtigt, bis sich Gott sei Dank in Anführungszeichen Christensen verletzt hat. Diese Verletzung hat man ausgenutzt, um Dani Olmo einschreiben zu können. Sonst hätte es finanziell nicht gereicht in Spanien. Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zur Info. Gibt es den Salary Cap? Also das heißt, du darfst nicht mehr ausgeben, als du einnimmst. Und dementsprechend hast du ein fixes Gehaltsbudget. Da müssen deine Lizenzspieler reinpassen plus deine ganzen Vereinsangestellten. Und die hat Basa traditionell, würde ich schon fast sagen, überstrapaziert. Deswegen war die Geschichte mit Dani Olmo schwierig. Aber sie haben es dann geschafft durch die Verletzung von Christensen. Und jetzt im Winter, als Christensen wieder fit wurde, wollten sie dasselbe machen über die Verletzung von Ter Stegen, der ja bis Ende der Saison nicht mehr spielen wird. Aber das hat nicht so ganz geklappt. Und dann musste natürlich Basa nochmal nachlegen irgendwie. Und dann haben sie argumentiert mit einem neuen Nike Deal, den sie im Sommer glaube ich schon abgeschlossen haben, hat die Liga dann zurückgewiesen. Und dann haben sie es dann trotzdem irgendwie noch geschafft oder beziehungsweise an VIP Plätze verkauft im neuen Stadion, an einen arabischen Investmentfonds und haben da anscheinend nochmal 100 Millionen eingenommen. Trotzdem hat die Liga das noch abgelehnt und hat das irgendwie glaube ich auch damit argumentiert, dass das jetzt nicht in die aktuelle Saison mehr reinpasst und so weiter und so fort. Dann ist Laporta, der Präsident von Basa, nochmal vor den Spanischen Sportrat oder den Spanischen Sportgerichtshof gegangen und die haben ihm dann Recht gegeben und dementsprechend haben sie dann die Spielberechtigung bekommen für die Supercopa. Also es ging nicht nur um Dani Olmo, sondern auch um Pau Victor, das ist ein Spieler, der letztes Jahr in der zweiten Mannschaft noch gespielt hat. Es ist aber jetzt noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar, Max, ob sie wirklich in der Liga spielen dürfen, denn Liga-Chef Javier Tebas ist nach wie vor dafür, dass sie nicht die Ausnahmeregel bekommen, die der spanische Stadien eigentlich eingeräumt hat. Also das Ding ist noch nicht so hundertprozentig durch. Sie prüfen also in der Liga immer noch alles, was geht, um diese Spieler nicht einschreiben zu lassen. Und da geht es gar nicht darum, dass man, glaube ich, Barca ans Bein pinkeln möchte, wenn ich das so sagen darf, sondern es geht einfach um einen Gerechtigkeitssinn. Man hat in Spanien diese Vorgaben, die sind sehr hart, die sind aber auch gerecht und die sind eigentlich auch, glaube ich, in Europa relativ einmalig und eigentlich schon ein positives Beispiel oder ein Vorzeigmodell, wie ich finde. Andere Teams mussten darunter leiden, unter anderem mein Club, der FC Malaga. Ich darf das ganz kurz nur reiß das ganz kurz ab. Vor drei Saisons in der Covid-Saison haben wir dieses Budget überschritten und haben eine Sperre aufgesetzt bekommen, die da hieß, wir dürfen nur 18 Profi-Spiele haben und dürfen das über eineinhalb Saisons auch nur machen. Und müssen uns halt dadurch ja quasi wieder refinanzieren, sozusagen. Und das war eine ziemlich harte Strafe. Malaga ist unter anderem dort dann eben auch abgestiegen, hat es aber dann trotzdem geschafft, ja einigermaßen mit diesen 18 Lizenzspielern dann irgendwie über die Bühne zu kommen. Aber es war natürlich ein krasser finanzieller Cut. Las Palmas hat sich beschwert, denen wurde auch damals eine ziemlich harte Strafe aufgerückt. Und auch Atletico Madrid hat sich beschwert. Andere Vereine haben sich beschwert und gesagt, es kann nicht sein, dass wir diese Regeln einhalten und Barca immer wieder eine neue Stellschraube findet und einen neuen Hebel findet, um das irgendwie hinzubekommen. Aber es ist halt der FC Barcelona und es ist halt ein Politikum in Spanien. Und man möchte seine großen Lieblingsvereine nicht in einen schlechten Schatten international stellen. Und dann, glaube ich, ist man so ein bisschen zu dem Schluss gekommen, ihnen diese Spielberechtigung zu geben. Ob die Liga jetzt wirklich nochmal was dagegen machen kann, also quasi ob die Liga über den Start da nochmal rüber hinweg entscheiden kann. Ich weiß, ich mag es, ich mag nicht da in die Zukunft blicken. Es ist wirklich in Spanien oft sehr diffus. Fakt ist auf jeden Fall, kein anderer Verein, außer vielleicht noch Real Madrid, hätte irgendeine Chance gehabt, dort was zu machen. Und es ist eigentlich schade, dass es jetzt so passiert ist. Mir tut es natürlich auch für die Spieler leid und für den Verein und für Flick und so weiter. Es ist sportlich natürlich eine wirklich bescheidene Situation, aber entweder gelten Regeln für alle oder sie tun es eben nicht. Und dementsprechend hätte man dort schon ein Exempel jetzt mal statuieren müssen, auch mal gegen die Großen. Aber es scheint eben wieder nicht der Fall zu sein und dass ja Barca sich wieder irgendwie drum herum mogeln kann.
Da wird es ja noch Berichterstattung zu geben. Da bin ich ganz sicher.
Ich geh davon aus.
Was magst du uns noch aus den Niederlanden erzählen?
Ich möchte noch einen Fokus legen auf den Abschließkampf in der Riedivisie, denn der wird langsam wieder richtig spannend. Also wir haben mit Almere und Walwag zwei Tabellen letzter, 17 und 18. Die dürfen es vermutlich nicht so einfach haben. Die haben zehn, elf Punkte. Aber dann haben wir mit Sparta auf dem Relikationsplatz jemanden mit 17 Punkten und Groningen und Almelo mit 20 und 21 Punkten. Und gerade dieser Kampf um 16, der könnte in den nächsten Spieltagen noch mal sehr groß auflammen. Denn Sparta hat das geschafft, nach 14 sieglosen Spielen mal wieder zu gewinnen jetzt. Und zwar sogar gegen Alkmaar, also gegen den Top Team der Liga. Und das Erstaunliche bei Sparta ist, dass sie wirklich immer, also wirklich fast immer, an sehr knappen Ergebnissen scheitern. Die haben von den 20 Spielen, die sie gespielt haben, nur vier Spiele mit mehr als einem Tor Unterschied verloren. Es waren also immer irgendwelche Unentschieden oder 1-0, 2-1, 3-2. Es war also immer knapp, die hatten nur gegen Gültrecht, haben sie immer 4-1 verloren. Das war die einzig große Klatsche, Anführungszeichen, die sie erleiden mussten. Und es waren immer so Nuancen, es war immer ein bisschen Spielluck dabei oder Pfech in dem Sinne für Sparta. Und jetzt scheinen sie so ein bisschen sich auch geschläggert zu haben. Vor dem 2-1 gegen ALKMA haben sie auch schon zwei Punkte entschieden geholt. Also haben auch wieder mal in Serie gepunktet und haben jetzt kommende Woche das direkte Duell gegen Kroningen. Also da könnten sie bis auf einen Punkt ran an Kroningen, an die nicht Aftis glätzt und könnten, sollte Almelo verlieren, auch Almelo überholen. Und für Kroningen war es auch sehr bitter, denn die hatten gestern Abend um 20 Uhr hatten die ein Nachruhspiel, nämlich gegen Almelo, also in direkten Konkurrenten auch wieder. Und in den Nielanden ist es relativ üblich, dass wenn Spiele abgebrochen werden, die Uhr angehalten wird, und es dann einfach ein paar Wochen später, man sich auf einen neuen Termin einigt und dann ab dieser Uhrzeit angehaltenen Uhr weiterspielt. Und Kroningen gegen Almelo war Ende Dezember abgebrochen worden, ich glaube in der 79. Minute aufgrund von Vandalismus und von Ausschreitungen in den Fan-Blocken. Dann ist dann auch ganz, ganz tragisch ein Kroningen-Fan aus vier, fünf Metern in den Innenraum gestürzt, der aber zum Glück im Krankenhaus dann auch behandelt wurde, und dem es wohl gut geht. Und dann hat man entschieden, das Spiel abzubrechen. Und das wurde jetzt eben gestern ausgetragen bei Stand von Minute 78 und 45 Sekunden. Gab es dann noch immer schöne, schöne Bilder, wo sich dann Aymilo-Fans Schaße gekauft haben, 20 Minuten alles geben für Heracles und sich damit abgelichtet haben. Und es blieb aber bei dem 1 zu 1, das war der Stand, bei dem es abgebrochen wurde und vorgesetzt wurde. Das heißt, reicht eigentlich nicht für beide Vereine. Ein Punkt ist dann zu wenig in dem Duell für 14 gegen 15. Und deswegen ist Sparta so ein bisschen in den letzten Tagen und Wochen der lachende 3., der jetzt eben regelmäßiger punktet, der diese knappen Spiele auch mal wieder für sich entscheidet nach 14 sichtlosen Spielen und der jetzt wirklich gegen Kroningen dann dann noch mal einen Big Step machen kann. Hat aber auch gestern nach der guten Nachricht des 1-2-1, aber auch die nächste negative Nachricht erhalten, weil Verscharen, ein wichtiger Spieler von Sparta, ist wechselt und zur 20. Endstrecke gegangen ist. Also müssen sie auch quasi gleich wieder einen Abgang verkraften. Aber ist zumindest wieder spannend im Abschließkampf. Und das kann man auch noch sagen, im Meisterschaftskampf ist es auch wieder ein bisschen spannend, weil sich eben Ajax ganz, ganz heimklammheimlich nach oben gemogelt hat. Es ist jetzt vier Punkte nur noch hinter Eindhoven, hinter PSV, hat auch noch ein Spiel weniger, könnte also auf einen Punkt rankommen, wenn sie zum Beispiel den Klassiker gewinnen gegen Feyenoord jetzt am Wochenende. Also auch spannend. Und fragt mich nicht, wie genau Ajax da aufgekommen ist. Ich hab es selbst nicht ganz so verstanden. Es ist Licht und Schatten. Wenn man sich an die Euroleague-Konferenz erinnert oder an die Euroball League, haben sie gegen Riga verloren. Das war, glaube ich, der erste Sieg. Football, Skoda, Riga überhaupt international. Ausgerechnet natürlich gegen Ajax. Und es ist so ein bisschen bei Ajax das Ding, dass sie sich sehr schwer tun mit dem Ball, wenn der Gegner einfach sich hinten reinstellt, kompakt und dicht ist und von Ajax verlangt, mal aktiv das Spiel zu machen. Dann fällt es Ajax auch mit den vielen jungen Talenten, die sie noch haben, auch wenn die meist sagtens wirklich herausstechen, so ein Fidget-Sim zum Beispiel. Aber dann fällt es Ajax doch schwer und schwierig, da das Spiel auch mal konsequenter zu machen und kreativer zu sein. Es sieht dann wieder anders aus, wenn sie einen Gegner auf Augenhöhe haben, der auch versucht mitzuspielen. Sie hier PSV, da haben sie ja auch gewonnen in der Liga zum Beispiel. Und das ist so ein Punkt, an dem Ajax noch arbeiten muss.
Also Spannung an beiden Enden der Tabelle mit unmittelbarem Ausblick nach vorne. Da haben wir auch schon ein bisschen so Matches to Watch jetzt mit dabei gehabt, sowohl eben bei Sparta als auch jetzt bei Ajax und im Ferien-Nordblock ja sowieso. Christian, was hast du denn noch aus der Serie A?
Ja, ich hab noch eine kleine nette Geschichte. Ich hab noch ein Player to Watch vielleicht, den die wenigsten auf dem Zettel haben. Wir gehen nach Venedig. Also wir sind auch im Abstiegskampf in Italien und zwar spielt da ein gewisser Philipp Stankovic. Und ja Stankovic, wenn jetzt bei ein paar da ein Lichtlein angeht beim Name. Das ist der Sohn von Dejan Stankovic von der Inter-Legende. Trippelsieger, ja 2010 mit Inter. Aber anders als sein Papa, der ja ein Mittelfeldstrategie-Arbeiter war, ist Stankovic Torhüter. Und zwar ein richtig guter. Also er kommt auch aus der Jugend von Inter, hat da alle, mehr oder weniger alle Jugendklassen durchlaufen, ist dann vergangenes Sondern Sampdoria ausgeliehen worden, in die zweite Liga hat da schon viel gespielt und ist jetzt eben im Sommer an Venezia ausgeliehen worden und ist jetzt wirklich, ist mittlerweile statistisch einer der stärksten Torhüter der Liga und hat einen riesen Impact auf diese Mannschaft. Venedik hat von den letzten acht Spielen nur zwei verloren, haben leider auch viele von unentschieden gespielt, also sind trotzdem, ja stehen in der Tabelle als Vorletzter nicht wahnsinnig gut da, aber Stankovic hat ihnen in jedem Spiel eben die Chance gegeben was mitzunehmen. Also wie gesagt, dass die von den letzten acht Spielen nur zwei verloren haben, lag wirklich in vielen Punkten an Stankovic überragend auf der Linie, wirklich ganz ganz großartige Reflexe. 23 Jahre jung, also für einen Torhüter noch sehr jung. Und es ist mittlerweile jetzt wirklich so, dass bei Inter, weil da geht es jetzt mittelfristig dann schon auch um die Nachfolge von Jan Sommer, also im Moment ist ja mit Sommer logisch alles noch gut, gar keine Frage, mehr als gut sogar, aber logischerweise ist Sommer halt auch in einem gewissen Alter. Und jetzt gibt es schon bei Inter einige, die sagen, oh mein Gott, haben wir da womöglich im Sommer nicht vielleicht ein bisschen was falsch gemacht, denn Stankovic ist zwar in Venedig ausgeliehen, aber die haben eine Kaufoption und die Kaufoption liegt nur bei zwei Millionen Euro. Und eigentlich geht im Prinzip jeder davon aus, dass Venedig das zieht quasi, weil der Markt wirklich schon extrem gestiegen ist. Inter hat zwar 50 Prozent weiterverkauft, Rechte quasi, also wenn er dann weiterverkauft worden würde, dann würden sie stark daran beteiligt werden, aber man darf auch nicht ausschließen, also wie gesagt, trotzdem gibt es ja gute Beziehungen zwischen Inter und Venedig, da sind immer wieder auch andere junge Spieler dahin gewechselt. Also lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich würde nicht ausschließen, dass Inter auch probieren wird Stankovic mittelfristig zurückzuholen und man muss ihm wirklich zutrauen, ich glaube, der hat das Potenzial wirklich mittelfristig die Eins bei Inter zu werden. Also es ist wirklich seit Woche, Woche für Woche wirklich herausragend. Klar, du kannst bei einer kleinen Mannschaft auch mehr glänzen, ist schon klar, weil er mehr aufs Tor kriegt, aber es ist wirklich, er gibt der Mannschaft Ruhe, ist wirklich richtig stark, statistisch wie gesagt einer der besten der Liga und dementsprechend merkt ihr euch den Namen, vielleicht ist schon bald wieder Stankovic bei Inter, nur diesmal auf einer anderen Position. Und der allerletzte witzige Satz dazu, in Interkreisen gibt es so ein paar Nostalgiker, die sagen bitte, bitte, bitte in ein paar Jahren, wir wollen nicht nur Stankovic im Tor, sondern wir wollen auch Klinsmann im Tor, denn wie ich sich vielleicht ein paar erinnern, der Sohn von Jürgen Klinsmann ist ja auch Torhüter und der spielt in der Serie B, also in der zweiten Liga, macht auch einen guten Job und deswegen ja in Inter-Fan-Kreisen, komm wir wollen dann irgendwann Stankovic im Tor. Also der zweite Teil ist jetzt eher lustig, aber mit Stankovic, das ist mehr als nur ein cooler Spruch. Also wirklich ein sehr, sehr aufstrebender, vielversprechender, starker Torhüter.
Spannend, sehr gut. So und jetzt hab ich noch ein Thema mitgebracht. Ihr müsst jetzt entscheiden, wie viel Zeit ihr noch habt. Wir sind ja eigentlich schon nahe dem Ende. Aber weil mir das einfiel, wir haben ja in der Unsung Hero Kategorie hier so oft Trainer mit dabei, interessante Trainer-Talente. Und jetzt haben wir ja mit dem BVB einen Verein, der einen neuen Trainer braucht und dem einen Impuls von außen sehr, sehr gut täte. Und nach allem, was man bisher hört, sind aber nur die üblichen Verdächtigen, plus noch Alf Rangnick in der Verlosung bei BVB. Ist mir jetzt völlig egal, was davon realistisch ist. Aber ich hätte jetzt an euch die Frage und bin gespannt, wie ihr antwortet, welche Trainer-Talente, bei denen es halbwegs realistisch wäre, dass sie auch zum BVB kämen, also braucht jetzt nicht Hansi Flick sagen, gäbe es denn in euren Ligen, die vielleicht sogar verfügbar wären oder die gerade bei einem Verein wären, wo man sagen würde, ey, der Schritt nach Dortmund könnte sich auch lohnen. Fabian, hast du da einen Namen für mich?
Den ich vorher genannt hab von Rayo Vallecano, der ist mir noch zu jung, mit 37, das ist der Schritt, Dortmund kommt natürlich zu früh. Aber es gibt natürlich schon spannende Trainer in Spanien, ob das jetzt Ernesto Valverde von Bilbao ist oder zum Beispiel Marcelino von Villareal. Aber ich trau denen nicht den Schritt zu Dortmund zu. Auch der Schritt damals von Marcelino zu Olympique Marseille ist ja auch gescheitert. Das sind Spieler, die funktionieren, glaube ich, gut in Spanien, aber nicht außerhalb. Es gibt aber einen spanischen Trainer, den ich extrem interessant finde und der mit Sicherheit dorthin passen würde. Das ist Andoni Iraola, Trainer vom Bournemouth, der im Moment, ja, weiß ich nicht, so in der WM vierter, fünfter oder so. Er macht einen unheimlich riesigen Job. Schon letztes Jahr, wie ich finde, der hat vorher auch Rayo als erste Trainerstation gehabt. Rayo war ja Kano, das ist ein Sprungbrett für interessante Trainer in Spanien, war jahrelang Rechtsverteidiger bei Athletic Bilbao, ist nie gewechselt, war immer beim selben Club und ist unwahrscheinlicher Fußball, was heißt Lehrer, Philosoph auch. Und was der mit Bournemouth macht, ist unglaublich. Der würde Dortmund aber mal richtig gut zu Gesicht stehen. Aber ich habe fast eher bei ihm das Gefühl, dass es nächste Session noch eine Stufe vielleicht sogar weiter nach oben geht als bis zum BVB.
Könnte schon zu groß sein für den BVB, meinst du. Aber klar Bournemouth gerade Tabellen siebte, über die hätten wir vielleicht geredet, wenn wir Pramilic heute mit dabei gehabt hätten. Also das ist absolut fantastisch.
Also der ist wirklich herausragend. Ich habe jetzt viel auch aus Italien von Kollegen mitbekommen. Vielleicht zur Einnung ist ein Bielsa Schüler. Also ganz, ganz viele Grundprinzipien vom Bielsa. Also was der mit denen da oben macht, das ist ganz großes Kino. Also ich glaube auch, dass der vielleicht schon in anderen Sphären auch schon, nicht nur vielleicht auch schon gehandelt wird. Also ich glaube, das wäre ein Riesenstil für Dortmund, wenn ihnen das gelingen würde.
Ja, Tottenham braucht ja vielleicht bald jemanden. Ja, das könnte das Näherliegende sein. Ja, Christian, wenn du jetzt grad eh schon mit dabei warst, also gerade bei Italien hatten wir das ja in den letzten Jahren so oft, dass wir über interessante Trainer gesprochen haben. Du hast ja vorher auch schon wieder eine ganze Reihe von Trainern genannt. Wen gäbe es denn da, wo du sagen würdest, können ja auch mehrere sein, die könnten passen?
Also ich fange erstmal mit denen an, die verfügbar waren, wären, jetzt schon quasi. Das sag ich einfach mal Roberto Mancini und Daniele De Rossi. Meine Meinung zu De Rossi kennt er ja. Also ich finde, der würde jeden gut tun und ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob De Rossi und Dortmund, ob da irgendwie Berührungspunkte sind. Was ich aber bei De Rossi glaube, ist, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit gar nicht so klein ist, dass der erstmal ins Ausland geht. Also bei dem könnte ich mir gut vorstellen. Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass der jetzt schon im Sommer, dieses Jahr nimmt man sich jetzt einfach noch nach dieser ganzen Roma-Nummer glaube ich, nimmt man sich bewusst raus. Aber im Sommer ist er sicher wieder ein Kandidat für, da werden auch im Hintergrund schon Gespräche laufen. Und ich kann mir bei dem vorstellen, dass der wirklich auch vielleicht erstmal einen Schritt raus als Italien machen möchte, um dann wieder zurückzukommen jetzt mit dieser ganzen emotionalen Roma-Nummer. Aber ein Trainer, der ist so ähnlich wie bei Fabian. Und ich hatte halt auch das Zufall, dass wir ihn vorhin hatten, aber ich finde von der Art und Weise, wäre Vincenzo Italiano wirklich einer, der sehr gut zur Bundesliga auch passen würde. Es ist wirklich dieses Gegenpressing, dieses wirklich intensive Spiel, das der Pater Fiorentina schon aufgezogen hat, das er jetzt mit Bologna weiter durchzieht. Also von der Art und Weise muss ich sagen, wäre das wirklich was, glaube ich, was passen könnte. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass Italiano, das ist schon auch einer, der gerne was aufbaut. Deswegen glaube ich kaum, dass du den jetzt auch im Sommer aus Bologna wegkriegst. Weiß ich nicht, ob der gleich schon geht. Vor allen Dingen spielt er womöglich nächstes Jahr auch wieder europäisch mit Bologna. Aber nur rein vom Typ her, weil du ja meintest, Max eben was könnte passen, ist das wirklich was, glaube ich, was sehr gut zur Bundesliga passen könnte. Weil es Grundprinzipien von dem, starke Bezugspunkte zur Bundesliga gibt. Eine Sache, die kann man jetzt ja dann noch einbauen, die hatte ich vorhin noch nicht erwähnt. Es ist nicht nur Pressing und Gegenpressing, sondern Bologna hat auch den dritthöchsten Ballbesitz in der Liga. Also die haben knapp nach Inter und Juve. Also das ist auch eine dominante Mannschaft. Das ist nur, wenn der Gegner den Ball hat, dann beißen sie zu und schnappen rein. Aber die können durchaus was mit dem Ball auch anfangen. Es ist nicht nur eine reine Truppe, die nur auf wilde Ballgewinne geht, sondern das ist eine sehr gut strukturierte Mannschaft, die aber wirklich als Riesenplus und in Italien ragt es vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr raus als in der Bundesliga. Wirklich dieses wahnsinnig intensive Pressing und Gegenpressing und anlaufen hat und dementsprechend. Also ich finde Italierner auch schon länger, glaube ich, hatten wir hier auch schon ein, zwei mal einen sehr spannenden Trainer. Also das wäre vielleicht einer vom Profil her.
Und der Rossi war in Dortmund, das könnte man sich auch sehr, sehr gut vorstellen, egal wie realistisch es ist. Eine kurze Beobachtung übrigens zum Pressing, ganz interessant. Die Bundesliga ist da gar nicht mehr so wie ihr ruft. Wenn man sich nämlich zum Beispiel die PBDA-Werte anguckt von den Top-Leagern, dann siehst du, in Deutschland nur ein Team mit einem Wert unter zehn. Und da hast du in La Liga irgendwie acht Teams.
Unter zehn, genau, gepayern, gell?
In der Serie A sechs Teams. Echt acht? Ich glaube schon, es waren sehr, sehr viele. Ich muss noch mal gerade nachgucken in irgendeiner der Ligen, wo ich geguckt habe.
Ich hab's vorhin auch, weil das hat mich jetzt...
Fünf waren's in der Premier League.
Nee, schau in Italien. Sorry, schau in Italien, ist das wirklich nur Bologna unter zehn. Es sind dann einige mit zehn, das stimmt. Mit zehn hast du dann Lazio, Inter, Juve, Atalanta, die sind alles so um zehn rum. Aber unter zehn hast du zum Beispiel wirklich nur Bologna. Das ist ja sogar unter acht.
Ich hab mich gerade in den Ligen geirrt, genau. Also auf jeden Fall, was ich nur damit sagen wollte, dieser Pressing-Liga-Aspekt, den es gibt, die Liga war das mit den vielen Teams, Entschuldigung, da waren es richtig viele, sieben Stück unter zehn. Aber das stimmt gerade gar nicht mehr so. Warum? Weil sehr viel Mittelfeld-Pressing, Union hat der Liga da ein bisschen was beigebracht, deswegen alle eher in so einem abwarten 5-3-2 oder 5-2-3 und mal situativ rausrücken. Und du hast halt mit Leverkusen und Stuttgart und in Teilen mit Bayern, je nachdem welcher Trainer gerade da war, hast du Teams, die dich halt brutal dafür bestrafen können, wer dir einfach zack, zack, zack durchspielen. Und das schafft inzwischen auch Mainz und Fünf, St. Pauli schafft das auch hin und wieder. Deswegen, entweder ist die Bundesliga da weiter als andere Ligen, ist das quasi schon die Reaktion auf das Pressing oder sie hängt zurück. Das muss ich zum Glück nicht beantworten. Daniel, ich habe mehrfach gelesen von BVB-Fans, wir brauchen jetzt unseren Louis van Gaal, jemanden, der wie damals beim FC Bayern reinkommt und einmal aufräumt und einmal sagt, hier guck mal, Fußball funktioniert übrigens so. Gibt es den neuen Louis van Gaal?
Nein, also das ist glaube ich gut so. Ich glaube, Louis van Gaal und BVB, als ich das Gerücht gesehen habe, war ich noch sehr froh.
Nicht ihn selbst, aber quasi diese Art Trainer quasi.
Auch diese Art Trainer würde ich beim BVB eigentlich ungern sehen wollen. Ich hatte an einen anderen Typen gedacht, der jetzt nicht knurrt, es ist kein Knurrhahn ist, sondern auch kein Talent mehr ist, der ist 66, sondern Ron Janz von FC Utrecht. Die hatte ich glaube ich hier auch schon mal vormistet in der älteren Folge, glaube ich. Und der ist einfach, der bringt unfassbar viel Erfahrung mit. Der war auch in den USA bei Cincinnati und hat aber auch in der Eredivisie eigentlich alles, was er angefasst hat, wurde auch irgendwie zu Gold. Also der hat Twente, die ja zwischenzeitlich abgestiegen waren, hat hier wieder zur Altersstärke hochgeführt. Da wurde mit den Fürther vor einigen Jahren und ist dann aus freien Stücken gegangen. Also da wurde er nicht rausgeschmissen, sondern er hat gesagt, okay, ich habe jetzt hier mehrere Jahre trainiert und gearbeitet. Wir haben viel erreicht und für mein Verständnis ist jetzt das, was ich erreichen konnte, erfüllt. Ich habe den Verein in einer guten Lage hinterlassen und es ist jetzt mal eine Zeit hier abzutreten, den Platz freizumachen für wen neu ist, um irgendwie eine neue Herausforderung zu suchen. Und die fand er in Utrecht und aktuell sind die auf Platz drei. Also macht er eigentlich genau da weiter, wo er bei Twente aufgehört hat, die jetzt auch echt, ich glaube auch, dass Utrecht am Ende der Saison Europäisch spielt, jetzt nicht zwingt Champions League, aber durchaus Europäisch spielen wird mit Conference oder Europa League. Und er hat so sein System, er hat so sein 4-2-3-1-System, was er macht, was ja in Dortmund auch vorstellbar ist. Und ich meine, da auch schon gespielt wurde eigentlich. Jetzt wird's gegen die Prämie auch. Und das passt also schon gut. Aber er hat einfach auch diese Erfahrung, er hat die Ruhe, er lässt auch viel pressen in dem System und er hat so ein bisschen, er ist auch sehr polyvalent quasi so ein bisschen. Also er hatte, er war mal bei Zwolle, es war in den 14, 2014, 2013, 14, da hat er wirklich die defensive Trickkiste ausgepackt und wirklich sehr kompakt hinten gestanden und wirklich sehr versucht, Flusskante dort zu kassieren, hat sich dann aber in den Jahren weiterentwickelt, auch gerade nach Cincinnati und bei Zwente und hat angefangen, wirklich ein Kombinationsspiel aufzuführen. Und ich glaube, diese Mischung würde Dortmund gut zu Gesicht stehen, dass sie eben diese Abstimmung, gerade diese Konterabsicherung, gerade so die defensive Abstimmung, die ja bei Dortmund durchaus nach Akiri ist, in dem letzten Spiel gewesen ist. Da könnte Ron Janss einer sein, der da wieder ein bisschen bessere Balance herstellt, ohne aber das offensive Gewalt zu vernachlässigen, was du ja mit dem Kader von Dortmund auch nicht kannst. Insofern ist das einer, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, das könnte passen. Verfügbarkeit ist die andere Frage. Ich könnte mir aber gerade bei ihm auch vorstellen, dass er nach der Saison, wenn jetzt Dortmund eine Übergangslösung, gibt ja auch verschiedene Modelle, die im Gespräch sind beim FVB, dass jemand für die Halbserie jetzt noch kommt und im Sommer eine neue Lösung kommt, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass er sagt, okay, ich hab bisher auch bei Utrecht erfolgreich gehabt, eine gute Zeit gehabt, ich hab die auf Platz drei, vier, wo auch immer abgeschlossen und bin dann noch bereit noch mal für einen Schritt ins Ausland. Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Die Frage ist, ob generell die Frage wird sein, ob Dortmund einen eher unbekannten Namen sich daran traut oder ob es dann auch vom Nachmittag die größere Lösung sein muss. Da fällt dann wer wie Erikton Haag zum Beispiel ins Auge, der ja auch angeblich schon im Stadion war und so. Aber ich persönlich würde mich freuen, wenn Ron Janz es wäre, auch wenn ich es nicht glaube.
Wenn ihr mehr zu Ron Janz wissen wollt, liebe Hörer, dann hört die Ligatur vom 31.10. des letzten Jahres. Da haben wir eben länger über Ulrich gesprochen. Da hast du uns das alles schon mal erzählt. Ja, mal gucken. Vielleicht bekommt er dortmit auch seinen neuen Bert von Marwijk. Da hat er ja durchaus schon seine Erfahrungen gemacht. Ja, danke euch nochmal, dass wir diesen kleinen Schlenker noch machen durften. Christoph, wolltest du gerade noch was sagen?
Max, ganz kurz noch, sorry. Ja, sorry, nur ganz kurz, weil ich extra nochmal, weil ich es jetzt eben auch so spannend fand, ich habe jetzt auch nochmal in die Daten ein bisschen reingeklickt. Also es ist, die Kombination bei Italiano ist wirklich eine Spezielle, weil er eben auch diesen hohen Ballbesitz hat. Also quasi, es gibt ja dann viele Teams, die haben diesen hohen PPDA-Wert, aber die sind dann schon teilweise, zum Beispiel Mainz habe ich mir jetzt noch kurz mal rausgeschaut, die haben halt einen Ballbesitz von 47 Prozent. Also da geht es dann schon auch über das Element quasi und Bologna finde ich verknüpft das ganz gut, weil es ist eben, deswegen wollte ich es nur noch mal sagen, das ist nicht nur eine reine Gegenpressing-Mannschaft, sondern es ist eine Mannschaft, die es schon liebt auch den Ball zu haben. Und noch mal, die sind bei 57 Prozent in der Serie A, nur Inter und Juve haben ein bisschen mehr. Die sind vor Milan, vor der Roma, vor Napoli, vor Atalanta. Also die Kombination da glaube ich ist schon ganz eine spannende, dass du das mit Ballbesitz aus einer guten Struktur heraus dann in Kombination mit Aggressiven und Intensiven.
Und irgendwie wär es doch nett, wenn Dortmund ins Bayern-Playbook greift und sich den Trainer des Teams ruht gegen, dass man eine habe Klatsche auf hat. Das ist ja auch ganz nett. Das ist Rheumakei mit anderen Mitteln und in anderer Konstellation. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich, das hat große Freude gemacht. Das nächste Mal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, werden wir wahrscheinlich auch wieder andere Ligenkombinationen mit dabei haben. Es ging sich diesmal nicht so aus. Aber ihr kennt das ja aus der Ligatur. Hier wird ein bisschen durchrotiert, so wie es ja auch sein soll. Ich danke sehr, sehr herzlich Daniel, Fabian und Christian. Danke, dass ihr hier mit dabei wart und euch die Zeit genommen habt. Danke euch.
War wie immer schön.
Sehr gerne.
Sehr schön war es.
Und ich freue mich natürlich auch, dass Sendungen wie diese hier möglich sind, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und zwar allein durch euch. Ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsor- und frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrtihr, wie das geht. Oder einfach auf rasenfunk.de und auf den unterstützen Button klicken. Und in dieser Folge bedanke ich mich bei Wasserturm 68165, bei Bene, bei Alex T., bei Tom K aus M., bei Alex, bei Lydia, Wildpark, Panda und bei Enro. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Und an dieser Stelle auch gerne der Hinweis, wenn ihr Feedback habt, dann könnt ihr uns dieses geben auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de in unserem Forum und abonniert doch sehr gerne auch die anderen Feeds, die es gibt vom Rasenfunk. Also zur Bundesliga der Männer, zur Bundesliga der Frauen, zu Nationalteams. Da sprechen wir über alle Nationalteams, Spiele Deutschlands und über die großen Turniere und das Tribüngespräch. Da gibt es jetzt auch eine neue Folge zum Polizeikostenurteil. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bis bald, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!